e
the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative osbor who moves
the house ad Jour from the session of
March 14th 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I those
oppos nay the eyes have it the house is
adjourned the house will attend to a
Prayer by house chaplain Reverend Bob
Smith pastor of St Paul's United
Manchester
good morning Mr Speaker good morning New
Hampshire House of
Representatives let us prepare our
prayer good morning God of our
hearts you yearn to be so close to us so
we can know you in every breath in every
hope in in every relationship
and so we come to you seeking to be made
whole in and through you oh
God Place Your Love within us as you
wrote it on our
hearts that you may be our God and we
may be your
people oh God we ask that you be with
representative art Ellison who is
currently under hospice
care we ask that you tend to him and his
family oh god of
Covenant we come to you tired and worn
at times yearning for peace and Harmony
in our lives yearning for peace and
Harmony in our
communities yearning for peace and
world be with each of us today so that
we can bring that peace and Harmony here
here to our great state of New
Hampshire guide us oh God as we begin
the work today on all the legislation
that is presented before us and help us
to make the best decisions possible that
will affect the many constituents
represented here
today oh god of love again I ask that
you bless each member and leader of This
House of
Representatives grant them your peace
peace and Grace and extend your peace
and Grace to their respective
families give each member and leader a
portion of your wisdom as they execute
the business of this
day oh God we give you the glory and
praise that you are so deserving of from
us this day and every day it is in your
amen
the chair recognizes a member from
Bristol representative John CIS who will
America stands
na
all the chair now recognizes the m from
Bristol representative Carol Brown who
will sing on National
Anthem oh can you
see by the dawn's early light what so
proudly we
hailed at the twilight's last
gleaming whose broad stripes and bright
stars through the
pous
fight all the ramp parts we watch were
so
gallantly
streaming and rockets red
glare the bombs
buring in air gave proof through the
night that our flag was still there oh s
he does that star
spangled
we for the
land of the
free and the
[Applause]
bra
the house will attend the house will
attend to request for Le of absence Mr
Speaker the day illness Representatives
Andrews Ellison Jack Michael Murray
James Murphy Panic Stephanie p Petri and
trevan the day important business
Representatives McKenzie money PR and
Vincent the day illness in the family
representative
sandborn these leaves shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend the introduction
of guests Mr Speaker please welcome
Caitlyn French student at Bedford High
day
[Applause]
Mr Speaker please welcome Walt Hennings
and paully low guest of Representative
Andrews Mano Tera guest of
Representative Darby Amy J guest of
Representative Susi Thomas and Ellen
colb guest of Representative n
Franchesca Penza daughter of
Representative Penza and students from
Nash's Ledge Street School guests of
Representatives plamondon bman and Fred
Davis they are with us in the gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
[Applause]
house the house will now attended a
consent calendar Mr Speaker from the
committee on Judiciary House Bill 1640
removed by Representatives Hull Tom
Manion SRO Drago Phillips kushman Gard
Granger marter and
Penza
are there any other bills to be removed
representative Osborne moves at a
consent calendar the relevant amendments
as printed in today's heal's record be
adopted are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay the eyes haveit the consent calendar
is
adopted recognize the clerk for an
announcement thank you Mr Speaker
members of the house this we have a new
change in our policy for
voting when a question is put for a
division or a roll call the
sergeant-at-arms will exit the chamber
and yell roll call or division down the
hall as you have heard uh at this time
um the sergeant has a new stopwatch and
will set it for a
minute uh at the conclusion of the
minute the door will shut if you are on
your way back the door will remain open
for you um that is a new change the the
other issue however is If U as we last
week had several divisions in a row that
there were just parliamentary inquiries
um if nobody has left the chamber and on
the previous vote everybody voted I will
inform the speaker that nobody has left
or come back and we can therefore
proceed to vote without having to expend
that minute so that is the change in the
calendar the committee on children the
family law to which was referred House
Bill 1192 FN an act relative to contempt
actions in domestic Rel relations
matters having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation Bill ought
to pass with Amendment representative of
Deborah D Simone for the committee the
amendment is
0914 printed in house record 11 page 50
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the bill is now aut
to pass with Amendment the chair
Greg for what reason does a member
rise a true parliamentary
inquiry State your inquiry um given that
you uh the clerk just read some policy
changes is that not something that we um
should vote on as as a rule change by
the house it's not a rule it's it's not
a rule change we're trying
to make everything more proficient it's
rule chair recognize representative
Greg
thank you Mr Speaker good morning in the
children and family law committee we
hear a lot about agreed parties parents
spouses grandparents and caregivers
there are warranted frustrations within
our system especially in cases of
custody parenting time and child support
matters on the special committee looking
at the family courts we took a close
look at the bottlenecks that can prevent
justices from happening happening within
the family courts as a matter of fact in
this body we have already passed a
wellth thought out bipartisan
legislation derived from the committee's
work that covers the Notions that this
bill is looking to
remedy this bill states that it give
judges gives judges latitude to assess
penalties they already have that this
bill also proposes that parents be
incarcerated as a remedy to an
incredibly complicated situation putting
something like this in legislation would
do the opposite of what we are working
towards wanting families to be able to
work together when possible this bill is
not helpful and it is not necessary I
urge you to push the red button so that
a more appropriate motion can be made
thank you the chair recognizes
Simone
thank you Mr Speaker for recognizing me
to speak on this important legislation
1192 I agree with most of what my
colleague just
said Mr Speaker House Bill 1192 as
consistency most of what my colleague
just said has nothing to do with
Court as you know I've been given the
honor of serving on children and family
law committee for approximately 16
years during my tenure on that committee
I've listened to testimony
from many constituents colleagues
agencies judges and attorneys concerning
the fact that one of the many
difficulties of divorce
proceedings
is and and I'm sorry and domestic
violence orders child visitation child
support and
alimony is how does the law provide
guidance to the court when a judge
presiding over that Court Court finds
that a person is in
contempt of a particular ruling in said
Court well it's not as simple as you may
think actually the answer is quite
complex because it
depends it depends on whether the
contempt issue constitutes criminal
Behavior civil Behavior or a ruling in
the Family
Court statistics are
showing that contempt Behavior has been
on the rise in Family Court people are
angry so even though when the court says
you will allow the child of the parent
to visit with that child you will pay
alimony people say I'm angry I'm not
contempt of court rulings verbiage is
completely
non-existent in RSA for uh title 43
domes C child support
guidelines and RSA 461 Child Support
Enforcement contempt violation verbage
only holds its place in the criminal
statute I can't imagine how frustrating
it must be for judges attorneys and
prosay litigants who are hearing or
giving their
cases in the Family Court House Bill
1192 as
amended speaks to that a judge in a
criminal court May refer to RSA 4 uh 544
40 and Rule 45 which is the criminal
content statute and Rule which clearly
gives guidance to the court on how to
rule when the contempt is direct
criminal contempt or indirect criminal
contempt and the operative words there
are
criminal the punishments are clearly
listed and decided by the judge
accordingly we find very few criminals
in the family
court in Criminal Court where you commit
a crime you are found guilty or not
guilty you are sentenced or not
sentenced by the standards of the law in
the Family Court which deals mostly with
emotional issues nobody's really guilty
of a
crime and more times than not no
criminal Behavior
exists just
anger judges still must make rulings
according to the clear concise laws set
before them with the exception of how to
rule on cases where it is believed and
perceived that someone is deplay
displaying contemptuous Behavior against
the Court's
rulings this is where unfortunately the
rsa's rules and laws are
silent this is why House Bill 1192 is so
important this bill speeds clearly to
contemp contemptuous behavior and
creates the necessary consistency in law
most people who commit contempt of the
rulings of the family court are not
acting in a criminal be manner as I said
so the penalties would not nor should
they be as severe as a criminal case and
this bill takes that into
consideration House Bill 1192 is really
just giving clear consistent guidance to
the family court where it is asked for
and needed finally Mr Speaker if I know
that attorneys judges prosay litigant
and prosay litigant have testified over
and over and over that guidance and
consistency in contempt violations would
be of great assistance to them and the
people that come before them and they
deserve the clarity that this bill will
bring then it only makes sense
Mr Speaker to press the green button and
pass this essential legislation Mr
you a division vote has been requested
by representative D Moone members take
your
seats
e
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended in House Bill 1192 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker good
morning
everyone if I know that the special
committee for the family courts has
crafted sensible legislation to resolve
these issues of
contempt if I know that the courts
already have the option to add penalties
for not adhering to court orders without
vindictive
measures and if I know that this bill
attempts a one-size fits-all measure
that historically has never worked when
it comes to the family court system
would I press the red button to oppose
this a to pass motion so another motion
can be made thank
you chair recognize representative D
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker if I don't recall any such
discussion as was just discussed by my
colleague during those committee
meetings
and I do
know that the family court laws rules
and rsas are silent concerning contempt
actions and this bill would speak loudly
and clearly to create consistency with
other rsas where it is defined and
necessary and if I know that those
contempt violations are continuing to
rise at an alarming rate and if I
further know that the judges attorneys
prosade litigants and families deserve
that guidance and
consistency then I know that I will be
pushing the green button and say yes to
pass this very important
legislation thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended in House Bill 1192 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present opportunity to vote
vote 187 voting a 178 voting a the
adopted
majority committee on children and
family law to which was referred House
Bill 1659 FN act relative to
interference with child custody and
sherid perington having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment recommendation to Bill ought
to pass with Amendment sen Deborah D
Simone for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
in expedient to legislate pres Heather
Raymond for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0921 printed in house record 11 page
66-67 are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppos
[Applause]
nay a
division division has been called
members take your seats this will be on
the amendment clarification
only
this is a clarification vote on the
amendment if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
if all members present have the
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 189 voting aay 176 voting nay the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass as Amendment chair
Ray thank you for your patience Mr
Speaker both child and family law and
the family court oversight committee
heard testimony about parents who
routinely ignore and violate parenting
plans this is a problem parenting plans
aren't just agreements between parents
they are court orders and there should
be consequences for repeatedly violating
the
terms however this bill is not the way
to address the issue this body has
already passed Bill's de session and and
just this morning that give both the
courts and parents tools and incentives
to enforce
compliance this bill however uses a
sledgehammer where a scalpel is needed
it treats every family's Circumstance
the same without regard for differences
and mandates that judges ignore the best
interest of the child in favor of
scripted compensatory time it ignores
complex family dynamics that families
experience
when parents behaviors don't quite cross
the line into serious injuries or abuse
for example if we have a 13-year-old who
presents with a large handprint bruise
on the face and says that Mom has been
drinking a lot and they've been fighting
DCF gets called they ask Dad to hold the
child for the weekend so that DCF can
fully investigate what's going on Mom
admits to drinking she drinks heavily
she admits to hitting the child because
the child is an adolescent and mouths
off
sometimes under New Hampshire
law this is an unfounded
report because bruising does not
constitute injury with protracted harm
or impairment and a 13-year-old is old
enough to call for help so being drunk
even habitually is not enough to make a
finding of
neglect therefore under the amendment
that we just just passed the family
court judge would be prohibited from
considering the best interests of this
child and would be required to award mom
compensatory parenting time to make up
for the weekend that she
lost DCF might recommend counseling or
parenting assistance but the way this
this bill is worded the judge could not
order it the judge would be required to
return to the original parenting plan
agreement
I don't believe that parents who act
with DCF to protect their children
should be punished because our abuse
laws require extreme injury before the
state can act I also believe that judges
should have the discretion to consider
all of the evidence before making
decisions not just rely on one piece of
evidence which is the DCF
report we have other bills that address
the cases where one parent basically
kidnaps the child
and we have better teeth for those bills
like the one we passed this morning
which would allow a judge to incarcerate
the parent who did the
kidnapping however this bill treats all
parents the same whether you've kept the
child for a weekend because you were
worried about their safety or you kept
them for two
years I ask that we support the previous
bills by pressing the red button on this
bill for itl I'm sorry to overturn turn
the OTP so another motion can be made uh
and I ask for a division vote thank
Pearson thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker in my role as
chairman of both children and family law
committee and of the special committee
for the Family Division of the circuit
court and also in my role as part-time
chief executive officer of a Kingston
Wellness Center which has two Physicians
and two certified counselors on staff I
have come to learn how many divorced
parents seldom or never see their
children despite court-ordered parenting
plans often the aggrieved parents then
went to the police and unless there were
credible allegations of severe abuse of
the child the police referred the
complainants back to the courts
in the research done as to what would
happen next I found a significant
variety across the country in some
states very red very blue and of various
shades of purple there are laws on the
books as to what the court may do next
to punish those disagreeing disobeying
parenting plans some states have felony
charges others misdemeanors to force the
parent guanting plan to be honored as
the court had originally
ordered however I also found that in
other states there are no consequences
to such willful contempt so the
perpetrators can continue to harm both
the other parent but especially the
child we need something more on the
books here in New Hampshire and is for
that reason that HB 1659 was
filed however in the children in family
law committee there was a concern that
the bill is originally submitted may
have gone a bit too far for example if a
child had been denied a visit to the
other parent on every other
Christmas the remedy would be for each
of those Christmases to be made up in
other words if the parenting plan called
for the child to visit one parent every
other Christmas and it was denied
twice upon conviction of defiance of the
plan the first parent would now have the
child for four consecutive
Christmases a bit much we
thought also the bill as originally
written would force the perpetrator upon
conviction to pay a fine of $500 for
every day of
non-compliance the amendment lowered
this to just one 500 payment for
non-compliance no
Sledgehammer also the amendment gave
more discretion to the judge reading
over this amendment yes more discretion
to the judge because as we all know no
two court cases are
alike so I believe the amendment we just
passed made a good bill much better and
much more
reasonable over the years in my
professional capacity I have witnessed
firsthand not only the utter sadness of
parents and grandparents who have denied
appropriate visits with their children
but also I have noted psychological and
emotional scars in the children denied
appropriate
visitation so I asked my staff
counselors what does dsm5 say this is
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders fifth edition published
in
2013 which is the taxonomic and
diagnostic tool published by the
American Psychiatric
association in their section
v995 51 we find what is called
pathogenic parenting syndromes appearing
in
children sometimes when parents
weaponize the child as a way of wreaking
Vengeance against the other parent too
often this creates an observable level
of Psychopathology in the child and as
such is deemed psychological child
abuse all of this and much more in great
clinical and scientific detail confirms
what so many of us have observed in some
cases where a parenting plan is
willfully
disregarded I believe that house bill
1659 is amended gives the courts a
better enforcement mechanism against the
disregarding of court-ordered parenting
plans Mr Speaker I hope my colleagues
will push the green button and while I
know this phrase has become somewhat of
a cliche here I think this is true we
need to do this for the children thank
you Mr Speaker represent Sween has
requested a roll call as that's
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
for
the motion before us is the majority
committ report of autopass as amended in
House Bill 1659 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative long for
inquir thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that custody matters are of best
interest of the child and this bill
prevents the court from considering it
and if I also know if I also believe
that there are a lot of people that came
that are going through this issue and
this bill does not address them because
this bill doesn't become effective or
does not address anything prior to
January any order prior to January of uh
25 uh then would I press the red button
thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and good
morning if I know that when parents
weaponize the child as a way to get back
at the child's other parent it leaves
lasting scars on the child's emotional
well-being and if I know that if there
are no repercussions for misconduct the
likelihood that the offense will be
repeated
increases and if I know that this bill
as amended will help the course enforce
the parenting plan that when adhere to
properly is in the best interest of the
child then would I not Mr Speaker press
the why would I not Mr Speaker press the
green pass the bill as
am motion before us a majority committee
report of aut pass as amended andh House
Bill 1659 this a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
vote 198 voting a 74 or voting nay
Rems Mr Speaker I'd like to make a
motion what state your motion um to
print the remarks from the previous
debate in the Perman permanent journal
without
objection committee on criminal justice
and Public Safety to which was referred
House Bill 1528 an act relative to
reporting by the northern border
Alliance program consider the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation Bill a to
pass with Amendment pres of alisandra
Murray for the committee the amendment
is
0737 printed in house record 11 page 63
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose n the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is a to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say
iOS nay the eyes have it and committee
adopted for what reason the member rise
Mr Speaker for a motion State your
motion Mr Speaker in accordance with
part it's not it's not a motion oh I uh
I would like my dissent entered into the
house
Journal um pursuant to part the second
article 24 and the reason for my dissent
is the bill serves to gather data by
police agencies for the perceived
innocence of the data is already being
entered gathered in truth the data we
wish to have is is the person being
encountered a foreign National and if so
what is the country of origin asking for
an encountered person's race does
nothing but prove or disprove the police
are or are not racially profiling the
person they chose to detain for the
you for reason to member rise Mr Speaker
I wish to make a motion State your
motion I wish to remove House Bill 1336
table and I request a division vote
and
okay
the motion before us
is the motion before us to remove House
Bill
1336 from the table this is a division
seats
down
the motion before us to remove House
Bill 1336 from the table this is a
division vote chair recognizes
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
represents an unconstitutional taking uh
of property rights and nothing this in
this amendment uh actually does anything
to fix that uh then would I vote uh no
on the tabling motion uh and uh press
red please thank you chair recognize
representative Roy for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know this isn't anything to do with
an amendment but it has to do is
removeing the bill from the table so
that we might discuss a possible
Amendment would I vote green to find out
says the motion before us to remove
House Bill 1336 from the table is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button you're oppos or
button
represent
it all members present have an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 189 voting aay 183 voting aay I'll
1336 is removed from the
table
any Ro representative Roy moves a to
pass this bill came with no
recommendation he offers and he offers
four
Amendment
1271 seat is in your seat
Pockets
M thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker this bill represents
an unconstitutional taking of property
rights and unneeded interference in the
responsibility of every New Hampshire
employer to promote and to maintain a
safe
workplace what hb136 would do is make it
illegal for any New Hampshire employer
to have or to enforce a policy Banning
firearms from locked cars on the
employer's own property under this bill
it would not only be illegal for a New
Hampshire employer to have or enforce
such an a policy but also Employers in
our state would also be banned from even
asking employees if they have weapons
stored in their
cars the floor Amendment uh the
amendment before us now aims to take the
edge off this by limiting the reach of
this statute to employers who receive
public or uh who receive public or
private funds I would remind you that
there are employers of all sizes uh in
New Hampshire who have contractual uh
relationship with both the state and
federal governments uh and in 2022 alone
there were nearly 300 New Hampshire
small businesses who won $188 million uh
in contracts uh from the government uh
we also happened to have some extremely
large employers like baa systems uh who
it seems might have some pretty good
reasons for restricting uh firearms on
their
property to be very clear in this state
people who aren't felons domestic
violence offenders or subject to a
protective order have the right to
possess a firearm but there has never
been a right in this state to bring that
firearm to private property where the
owner has made it very clear to you that
they do not allow firearms on their
property one of the main advantages of
being a property owner is the right to
use your land as you see fit even if
others disagree with your
reasons one of the main advantages of
starting and running a business is to be
able to set policies that preserve
confidentiality govern acceptable
behavior and protect workplace safety in
a way that fits the culture that you're
trying to create as a business owner
even if some people object to these
policies or find them
inconvenient what this amendment and the
underlying though would do is impose a
one-size fits-all ban on all New
Hampshire employers uh that fails to
take into account even sensible
exemption exemptions so even an employer
who has no objections to the presence of
guns on principle may have very good
reasons for barring them from company
property is a general practice for
example a daycare center where an
unlocked car and a curious child could
lead to a tragedy a defense contractor
concerned about terrorism or a domestic
violence shelter all of those business
may have a very good reason not to want
guns anywhere near their property and
finally something that I wanted to call
your attention to uh that's in the
amendment in the underlying Bill itself
is a provision that basically provides
civil immunity to an employer if
anything bad
happens the reason that that's in there
is because there is a possibility that
something bad can happen as a result of
this law so what I would ask you to do
is to please put it all together uh
protect the rights of our employees of
our employers uh to protect their people
uh and please respect uh property rights
in this state thank you and I would urge
you to vote uh to vote no on the
amendment and to vote no on the
underlying Bill thank you J recognize
representative
Roy thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I am
just so grateful at my colleague's
newfound love of the
Constitution um this um that is great
that is amazing that we want to um how
will be in
order adults are
talking we have a constitutional right
to carry
firearms now I heard my colleagues last
time say but wait a minute we don't want
to interfere in private business and and
we heard that and that makes that makes
sense but if you get money from the
government from the taxpayer from our
pockets then you become liable to the
same rules as the government's rules so
if you have a business and you get money
from the taxpayer you cannot say to the
people that work for you you don't have
your constitutional rights so all this
does is it says any business who does
business with the government they cannot
ban people from Firearms they cannot
tell people they cannot have firearms in
their vehicles they cannot search their
vehicles again someone who can't bring
their gun to work can't have their gun
at all so for the vast majority of the
week except for two days you don't have
the Second Amendment so let's make sure
that our citizens have the Second
Amendment at all times not just on the
weekends I urge you to vote Yes on the
amendment thank
you president H has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
seats
e
the motion before us is a to pass on the
floor Amendment this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
Lane
all members present have an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the
vote 2011 voting aay 172 voting aay the
amendment is
adopted now now we're on to the motion
amended
representative roads has requested the
division
seats
mus go
first
motion before us is ought to pass on
1336 this is a division vote chair
recognize represented Muse for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
private property is private property
and if I know that imposing a one-size
fits-all solution on New Hampshire
employers that conflicts with their
workplace safety policies and that those
policies exist to protect the safety of
all employees and if I know that not a
single New Hampshire employer testified
in favor of this bill then would I press
a red button so that another motion may
be made thank
you CH recognize representative rhs for
a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know it's about the
Destin it's about the journey not the
destination and if I know because of
unintended consequences this body voted
to kill a very similar bill just a fre
month few months ago and if I know is
unfortunate that it is statistically
speaking in New Hampshire a child while
in daycare has more chances of being
harmed from an elected official would I
committee
the motion before us the house will be
in
order the motion before us is a to pass
as amended on 1336 this is a
Divi division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
seconds
[Music]
well members president opportunity to
nay committee on education to was
referred House Bill 1205 relative to
women's School sports this comes without
recommendation Senator
cordelli moves a to
pass and offers Amendment
0973 H printed in house record 11 page
50-
51 and we have a debate on the amendment
any not any we have a division on the
seats
clear
the motion before us is amendment
0973 H printed in house record 11 pages
seats this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your opposer press the red button
voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
represent
love all members present had opportunity
vote 190 voting a 177 voting a the
amendment is adopted we're now on to
pass as
Amendment chair recognizes
representative
Simpson thank you Mr
Speaker I rise in opposition to the otpa
motion on HB 1205 and I would ask my
colleagues supporting this bill to
reconsider their position for three key
reasons I have significant concerns
first with student privacy conc
concerning government documents second
with conflict with federal law and a
potential loss of federal funding for
school districts and third with issues
of gender
equality first HB 1205 as amended
requires that every single student
athlete from fifth grade which is
typically 10 years old through 12th
grade must provide their birth
certificate to be eligible to
participate in any sport any sport there
is no explanation in the bill as to who
collects the birth certificate who
verifies it whether it needs to be
stored at the school district for a
certain period of Time how often it
needs to be shown or if the
documentation is destroyed after a
period of time this bill requires
private documents to be submitted with
no steps to maintain family
privacy according to the bill if the
parents do not feel comfortable bringing
in the birth certificate because after
all we're Granite Staters and we care
deeply about privacy the parents who
want their child to participate in
Sports must provide other evidence but
there's no specification in this bill of
what other evidence is acceptable so a
student may need to disrobe in front of
a school official to prove who they are
so they can participate in sports for
fun with their friends we should all be
Gravely concerned about the Privacy
implications and potential violations of
this bill the second significant concern
is how hb25 conflicts with Federal Title
9 law Title 9 says that no person shall
on the basis of sex be excluded from
participation under any education
program or activity HB 1205 explicitly
states that girl sports teams quote
shall not be open to students of the
male sex end quote but Title Nine says
students cannot be excluded based on sex
from any activity this means that to
comply with Title 9 schools under HB
1205 will not be edible eligible for
federal funding if they offer a girls
team but not a corresponding boys team
as this bill says that boys cannot play
on teams that are designated for girls
only let's use volleyball as an example
if a school district does not have
enough boys to field a boy volleyball
team but the District offers a girls
volleyball team if HB 1205 were to pass
boys would be excluded based on sex from
participating in this activity excluding
boys from a girls team if there's no
boys volleyball team is a violation of
Title 9 to be clear hb1 1205 is in
direct violation of Title 9 and federal
funding to school districts could be
withheld however this bill does offer a
solution to this conflict with federal
law girls teams could instead be
designated as
co-ed but we should ask ourselves what
could happen if all girls teams are
designated co-ed in order to comply with
federal law
it is safe to assume that more cisgender
boys would participate which could then
limit the opportunities of girls and
bump girls off the starting
roster the supporters of this bill claim
to care about protecting women yet in
their apparent quest to exclude
transgender students from participating
they are directly harming cisgender
girls this isn't about transgender
athletes passage of this bill would
encourage or even require districts to
to eliminate girl Sports in order to
comply with Title 9 federal law so they
can continue to receive federal
funding this brings me to the third
concern protecting gender
equality Title 9 ensures that all
students have access to an activity and
cannot be excluded based on their sex
Title Nine protect student athletes
ensuring they can participate in the
sport at their school if it is offered
even if it's not offered for their
specific gender
Title Nine is how girls were able to
start participating in sports in the
first place so they could have
protections and access so they would be
not excluded by boys only teams HB 1205
sends New Hampshire Back to Before title
n was passed in
1972 we would be responsible for
eliminating opportunities for student
athletes across the state by passing a
law in direct conflict with Title
9 I also want to address a story that's
been told in the public hearing and the
executive session for this
bill the story is about a field hockey
game in which a girl was injured she was
hit in the face by a field hockey ball
and it was a significant injury this
story has been used to blame a
transgender girl but that's not the
truth the student who hit the ball is a
cisgender boy born a boy identifies as a
boy has no question he is a boy the
student student is not
transgender pointing to that story as a
reason to pass this bill is misleading
that story has been misrepresented to
Target transgender girls it is not true
here's the reality anyone who has played
Sports knows that injuries happen all of
the time my son was a baseball pitcher
in his time as a pitcher he threw a lot
of strikes struck out a lot of batters
he also threw a lot of balls walked
batters and like every single pitcher in
baseball and softball he has hit
batters under no circumstances was he
blamed for the injury nor was he ever
the subject of intense media scrutiny or
the target of harassment or attacks by
peers coaches parents or the general
public think back to when you played
Sports you must have pulled calf muscles
torn acl's jammed fingers or like me
been hit by a baseball and a softball
we should not blame any student athlete
for an injury regardless of their
gender we would also never have rules or
pass laws that exclude students who are
much taller than others from playing
basketball because they have an
advantage we wouldn't exclude students
who are stronger than others from
wrestling because they might pin their
opponents in seconds we wouldn't exclude
athletes who have longer wingspans like
Michael Phelps from swimming we wouldn't
exclude athletes who have played on
private teams since they were little who
might have more experience than their
peers and are at an advantage this bill
targets a small group of student
athletes claiming there is a categorical
Advantage when there is not and it comes
with significant consequences for all
student
athletes and finally as I know this is a
concern of some of my colleagues there
have been zero transgender athletes in
the United States to receive an athletic
scholarship for college zero not just in
New Hampshire not just in New England in
the entire United States transgender
student athletes are not taking away
opportunities from cisgender student
athletes they are participating for all
of the same reasons my son played
baseball and throws the javelin they are
participating for the same reasons your
kids and grandkids play soccer and
football and ice hockey to learn a lot
of important life lessons from sports
like leadership confidence self-respect
and what it means to be part of a
team every student in New Hampshire
deserves those opportunities and should
not be excluded harassed or targeted for
wanting those same
opportunities I urge this body to vote
down the ought to pass
motion thank you chair recognize repr
Cent
Pento
thank you Mr
Speaker 10 years ago my daughter came to
me after cross country practice and said
mom there's a transgender on my team
this isn't fair what can we
do and I asked her if she wanted to make
a federal case out of it because I was
pretty sure that that's what it would
take and just last week 16 female
athletes filed a federal lawsuit against
the National Collegiate Athletic
Association for allowing biological men
to compete in women's college
sports why is this bill necessary and
others just like it across the
country because in
2010 glisten the gay lesbian and
straight education Network in
conjunction with the women's sports
Foundation the national Center for
lesbian rights and it takes a team
published a report to provide guidance
to high school and Collegiate athletic
programs about implementing policy to
allow transgender student athletes Fair
respectful and legal access to school
sports
teams these policies were adopted by
state and Collegiate athletic
associations before athletes and parents
knew what was even
happening the New Hampshire inter
Scholastic Athletic Association was
among the first to adopt the policy
creating a situation where the only
method of recourse for displaced girls
is to file lawsuit or quit the
girls I am not here to argue whether or
not everyone has a right to access
sports teams we all want equal access to
sports but a girl should not be
displaced by a boy on a team designated
for
girls in committee we heard testimony
that transgender athletes are trying to
be their authentic selves and find the
self-esteem camaraderie and fun that
women and girls experience on sports
teams we received testimony about girls
losing to boys who would have been
ranked far lower had they competed as
boys and the chance of girls losing
scholarships and championships to boys
who are competing as
girls girls and women have been severely
injured by boys and men competing as
women in their
Sports we've even heard testimony from a
colleague that it really didn't matter
if a transgender athlete competed in
girls high jump because it was an
obscure sport that few would watch this
is
insulting
scholarships and Championship losses are
concerning but what about the girls who
are cut from
teams or are on the junior varsity team
because they have been displaced from V
Varsity by a biological male what about
the girls whose self-esteem and mental
health suffers because they can't live
out their true authentic selves these
girls work hard to to train and practice
only to have their dreams
crushed by allowing biological males to
compete in women's sports we are telling
our girls and women that they don't
matter that they need to put their own
goals and dreams aside for a boy or a
man to take their place that they need
to remain silent in the face of
Injustice we owe our daughters and
granddaughters more than this please
support ought to pass on house Bill 1205
Callen requested a roll call is that
sufficiently second it is officially
seconded this will be a roll call vote
[Music]
seats
e
house will be in
order the motion before us is autop pass
as amended on
12:05 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill has absolutely nothing to
do with the NCAA Federal suit this only
applies to New Hampshire students age 10
to grades
12 if I know that this bill also
requires that those same students submit
their birth certificate or undergo a
personal investigation by school
officials to prove what their body
actually looks like to participate in
any school
Sport and if I know that hp25 would
discriminate against a group of students
in direct violation of T Title 9
jeopardize school districts from being
able to receive those federal funds
which on the average is about $165
million a
year and finally if I know that all New
Hampshire students
regardless of gender race sexual
orientation sex religion economic status
deserve the opportunity to learn those
important life lessons in sports like
leadership confidence
self-respect what it means to be part of
a team would I now press the red button
so that another motion could be offered
thank you chair recognize representative
thank you very much Mr Speaker if I know
this bill protects the future of women's
and girls Sports and will be the
demise if we don't pass it of Title Nine
if I know by permitting biological men
who identify as girls to participate in
women's girls Sports create creates both
unfairness
and severe safety
issues and if I know that it is
scientifically a fact that on average
males are stronger faster and larger
than average
females and lastly if I also know by
continuing to allow males who identify
as girls or women to participate in
women's Athletics it will lead to the
end of girl Sports and and
significantly reverse the gains women
have made since the implementation of
title one would I then press the green
button in support of my granddaughter
who captained the indoor and outdoor
track teams at
Orono my daughter who ran for Texas A&M
and my other daughter who point guard
for Elmyra College when they won the
championship in basketball thank you
press the green
button the motion before us is aop pass
is amended in House Bill 1205 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you opposed
you'll press a red button voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 189 voting yay
1818 two voting a committee report is
adopted for what reason member rise for
a motion State your motion I would move
that the remarks on House Bill 1205 be
objection
for what reason do member rise Mr
Speaker having voting on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration on HB 1205
and urge the body to vote
no motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill
1205 are you a division has been
requested I was waiting for
that uh this will be a division vote
seats
the motion before us a reconsideration
in House Bill 1205 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30
seconds
represent
Hond
[Music]
all members president up to a vote El
vote 178 voting a 194 voting a the
motion
failed for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker having voting on the
prevailing side of HB 1336 I move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote
no
motion before us is to have
reconsideration on
1336 are you ready for the question a
division has been requested members
should be still in your
seats nobody left so we're going right
to the vote this is reconsideration of
1336 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 177 voting aay 195 voting aay
motion
fails committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1650 FN relative
the approval of alternative program
graduation representative luno moves
ought to pass chair recognizes
representative Alicia
leas for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I move indefinitely
1650 that is a proper motion the motion
before us is to indefinitely
1650 a division has been requested
seats representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
vote
C
the motion before us is indefinitely
chair recognizes sen valicia leas for a
parliamentary
inquiry if I know that this bill applies
to
all um programs not just learn
everywhere but also work to
learn uh if I know that this will hurt
those
programs so that kids who who want to
work on a construction site for instance
might lose that
opportunity and if I know that the
appropriate people to decide whether or
not somebody is um
discriminating is the Human Rights
Commission
not the State Board of Education would I
then vote Yes to indefinitely
postpone J recognize representative hall
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill applies to learn everywhere
programs such as first robotics and not
to Extended Learning opportunities such
as a mentorship on a construction site
and furthermore if I know that all learn
everywhere programs should have minimum
standards an approval process and
internal anti-discrimination policies
and practices in place and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that an ad hoc
committee made up of Educators should be
convened by the doe to review and report
on all learn everywhere applications
prior to State Board of Education
approval would I now press the red
button against the I indefinite
postponement and listen to debate thank
you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is inde
definitely postponement in House Bill
1650 this this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppos press the red button
seconds
[Music]
all members present an opportunity to
vote 192 voting aay 182 voting aay 1650
postp
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1654 FN relative to
review of Education Freedom account
service provided
this it's without recommendation for
what reason member rise Mr Speaker I
1654 motion is to indefinitely postpone
House Bill
1654 and representative Granger has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
vote
e
the motion before us is indefinitely
postponement of
1654 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative cadelli for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill would require the State Board of
Education to annual annually re review
each provider of services to EFA
students for compliance with
anti-discrimination laws if I know that
the uh real intent is to go after
religious schools who are the primary
provider of services but ignored our
Supreme Court decisions and our own
human rights laws which have an
exemption for religious
organizations Mr Speaker if I further
know that I contacted the Human Rights
Commission Executive Director who wrote
me back and I quote my concern on behalf
of the commission is that this piece of
legislation is an attempt to dilute the
power and authority of the Human Rights
Commission where I now press the green
button
chair recognize representative Cornell
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill simply requires that all
education Freedom account service
providers develop and Implement
anti-discrimination policies that comply
with state and federal laws and if I
know that businesses are already
required to comply with
anti-discrimination laws and if I know
that when I looked up Amazon's
anti-discrimination policy a very
detailed policy pops up including their
third service suppliers but then when I
looked up two popular EFA service
providers no policy could be found would
I then press the red button so that we
could overturn the indefinitely
postponed and have a discussion on this
bill motion before is indeep
postponement for H on Hospital 1654 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if your
oppos will press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
represent
bone all members present had the
opportunity to vote also attend to say
world 191 voting a 183 voting a 1654 is
indefinitely
postponed
the committee on education to which was
referred hr30 urging a robust climate
education in schools including current
environmental and economic
information this comes without
recommendation presentive Damon wolves
ought to
pass and offers floor Amendment
0936 H printed in house record 11
Pages
67-68 the question on the amendment are
nay there will be a division vote for
clarification only members in the
seats
this is a division vote on
clarification if you're in favor of the
amendment you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote
181 voting aay 191 voting nay the
amendment
fails for what reason does the member
rise Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
postpone
hr30 the motion is to indefinitely
vote
oh
the motion before us is to inde defitely
postpone hr30 this is a roll call vote
also be in
order chair recognizes representative
iner thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the science
behind climate change is highly disputed
even among
scientists and that the sort of
agreement suggested by this resolution
does not
exist if I believe that this resolution
would promote a curriculum that would
discredit traditional reliable energy
industries that have not actually caused
a climate
crisis if I believe that climate anxiety
experienced by students today would only
be worsened by the sort of Crisis
mentality to be pushed by the
environmental curriculum this resolution
proposes would I now press the green
button J recognize represent of Damon
for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the adverse
effects of climate change on the New
Hampshire economy are clearly
established are profound and growing
including loss of jobs that are needed
to keep our young people here and if I
know that this house resolution is
simply allowing passionate informed
students to work towards factual climate
change education which would reduce
their anxiety and if I know these youth
are watching our votes today looking for
Hope and positive
change and deserve to see our Democratic
processes fully play out and have the
discussion this bill deserves would I
now enthusiastically press the red
button for a powerful statement against
indefinite
postponement the motion before us is
inde postponement on hr30 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're oppos
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
represent
Thomas
all members present have an opportunity
seat 191 voting yay3 voting
nay how authorties laid on the
table
Motion state your motion I would like
the comments from the previous debate to
be published in the journal
please without
objection
question well I'm sorry Mr Speaker I was
just curious to know do the uh remarks
from the previous debate include the
audience
for what reason did the B rise to make a
motion State your motion remove HB 147
from the table and I request a
division
call
represent runos requested the roll calls
that's officially seconded it is
officially seconded this will be a roll
call
vote
e
the motion before us to remove House
Bill 147 from the table this is a roll
call vote chair recognized
representative
Noble thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the state advisory committee on the
education of students with disabilities
has had some functional problems due to
the current size of the committee and if
I know that there is a floor amendment
to address the committee membership then
would I now press the green button to
remove the bill from the table thank you
J recognize representative Miler for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill was one of 10 bills that
the bipartisan committee House Education
moved to table if I know that on Friday
there was a scathing report on the
mismanagement of special education by
the L LBA and it was issued on Friday we
have not had a chance to look at it if I
know that the chair of our committee
chair lad has asked the LBA to come to
our committee and explain this special
education report and if I believe that
this amendment is premature prior to
that review by the committee would I
vote no by pressing the red button thank
you Mr
Speaker the motion before us to remove
House Bill 147 from the table this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
that
P I
have
all members present and an opportunity
vote 190 voting aay 185 voting a ALS
table the bill came to us without
recommendation representative Noble
moves ought to pass in office floor
okay
so okay chair recognizes representative
B
bony thank you Mr
Speaker HB 147 as amended would change
the membership of the state advisory
committee on the education of children
with disabilities a federally mandated
committee tasked with advising the
Department of Education regarding unmet
needs within the state in the education
of children with
disabilities I serve on that
committee it is required by federal law
to have a parent majority along with
several members representing different
professional educational roles for the
past few years this committee has not
been meeting its obligations of Duty or
Quorum the education committee devoted
much time and effort into study studying
the retain bill in
November we considered hours of
conflicting input from testimony
discussion phone calls and
emails from all the
parties there is no agreement among
among the committee members themselves
whether membership changes are
necessary but there is universal
agreement that obtaining a quorum for
meetings is an ongoing
problem everyone including the education
committee members want to see a
functioning vital special education
legislative advisory
committee
however the
amendment
only addresses committee membership and
does not provide solutions to other
identified issues such as lack of
sufficient administrative and technical
Education last week we received the
legislative budget Assistance Office
performance audit evaluating the
effectiveness of the dispute resolution
process of special education services
within the Department of
Education it has identified numerous
irregularities and non-compliance within
the
department it would be premature to pass
this bill without considering all
deficiencies noted within the
report future leg future comprehensive
legislation can address all identified
issues and
recommendations I urge you to vote no on
on the otpa so that a new motion can be
Noble thank you Mr
Speaker the state advisory committee on
the education of students with
disabilities is a committee that is a
federal requirement under
idea the purpose of the committee is to
advise the Department of Education on
issues relating to special education and
to promote communication and cooperation
among individuals involved with students
with
disabilities the committee has grown
quite a bit bigger than what is mandated
by the federal government and each time
you add someone you have to find more
parents or individuals with disabilities
because they must make up the majority
of the committee this has caused the
group to grow to about 47 people it
became clear during the hearing that the
committee has become largely
dysfunctional and in the just released
special education LBA audit the
committee is having some trouble
effectively performing their duties
because of this the most logical
solution at this time is to trim the
committee down to the federally mandated
membership which this amendment does but
adds a position requested by the
committee for a licensed health care
provider who specializes in working with
children and a non-voting state
education official to serve in a
technical support role this amendment
replaces the bill and will be a big step
in helping the committee to run more
effectively and I urge you to support it
vote on the amendment the question is on
12728 this is a division vote if you're
in
[Music]
favor
C
the motion before us is the floor
Amendment
1272 this is a division
vote chair recogniz Senor Miler for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr thank you Mr
Speaker uh if I know that the issue of
special education out of the Department
of Education is under full investigation
by the LBA at this point in time and
that the full report has not yet been
issued if I know that if I believe that
this amendment only deals with a very
small section of special ed services to
parents and if I believe that the the
education committee should have an
opportunity to review the current report
that was just issued last Friday would I
vot now vote no to allow the committee
to have a full look at this rather than
just trying to PC meal this together
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that the
state advisory committee on the
education of students with disabilities
will be much more effective with less
members and if I know that the committee
performs duties that are very important
to special education and it must
function well then would I now press the
green
button motion before us is the floor
Amendment 1272
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
seconds
[Music]
representative partial representative
Newman all members present have an
vote 191 voting yay 183 voting nay
committee amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is a to
pass as amended on heal Bill 147 roll
call roll call has been requested is
that that is sufficiently seconded this
vote
get
right the motion before us is a to pass
as amended in House Bill 147 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present had opportunity to
vote also tend to stay to the
vote 92 voting a 183 voting nay
adopted
committee on Election to which was
referred House Bill 10 74 relative to
campaign contributions by limited
liabilities companies representative
lame mes ought to pass the floor offers
Amendment
0630 printed house record 11 pages 44
through 46 are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
have it and the amendment is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise
thank you Mr Speaker I move to
1074 the motion before is indefinitely
1074 are you ready for the
requested
representative ger request a roll call
and that is sufficiently seconded this
vote
the
down the mo before us is inde definitely
postpone House Bill
1074 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press a red button
seconds
[Music]
represent all members president had an
opportunity to vote also tend to the
vote 191 voting yay 185 voting
postponed for what reason does the
member rise Mr Speaker having voting on
the prevailing side of House Bill 147 I
move reconsideration and urge the body
now
request
the motion before us is to reconsider
house bill 14
7 this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 182 voting a 194 voting aay
reconsideration
fa we have one lunchtime announcement
representative
Roseman thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to
invite everybody down to the cafeteria
there's some bipartisan Disability
Policy Representatives that have invited
us all to lunch so if you'd like to join
us down in the cafeteria it's in honor
of Jeff Dickinson from Granite State
Independent Living so join us thank you
we'll be in recess until
1:20
for
e
ction law to which was referred House
Bill 1098 relative to ballots delivered
to Elderly Care Facilities comes without
recommendation representative Barry
moves ought to pass and has asked for a
division vote members take your seats
vote
e
the motion before us is aut to pass on
House Bill
1098 this is going to be a division vote
the chair recognized representative raor
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill only enables local
election workers to deliver absentee
ballots to elder care facilities and
that these workers already have a full
workload and if I know that the current
process is functioning well in virtually
all facilities and if I know that a
similar bill was recently defeated by
this body then would I press the red
button so another motion could be made
thank you chair recognize representive
Barry for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
this bill is merely enabling uh
legislation and does not have a
requirement and Mr Speaker if I know
that there are many elderly voters who
wish to vote vote with their Town Clerk
or assistant clerk instead of a nurse
would I then press the green button to
uphold the committee recommendation of a
to pass the motion before us is aut to
pass on House Bill 1098 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposer
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
yes or
no
repr
Perez all members presing have
opportunity to vote house attendance
reported
for what reason does a member
rise Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I move that that
house bill 1414
be special ordered for the next order of
business do you want to speak to your
motion do you want to speak to your
motion yes uh Mr Speaker there are some
members of our delegation who need to
leave at at an early
hour okay we have some me members of the
county delegation who have to leave uh
soon and we'd like to have this this
this bill taken care of um before this
over this will be a division vote
seats
e
the motion before us is special order
House Bill 1414 for the next order of
business this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposer press the red
seconds
[Music]
representative Southworth representative
jurus please put your folders down thank
bailes
Walsh
all members present had an opportunity
vote 236 voting a 137 voting a it passes
voting
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
referred House Bill 1414 FN an act
relative to the Gunstock area commission
and Ski Resort considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to
legislate representative John McDonald
from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate representative Tim kahill
committee chair recognized
representative
cont
colleagues I know this is a
pretty political and emotional bill for
some of
us but I think the facts really need to
be
heard and I Rise before you today to ask
that you overturn the itl motion so that
the floor amendment can be brought
before you
and why is this so important you
ask why with all the controversy would
someone push for this when it would be
so much easier to sit back and let
things
unfold because it's the right thing to
do I would like to give you a little
history before I get into the nuts and
bolts of
things did you know that belnet Mountain
Recreation Area came into being during
the Great Depression
by the WPA or the works progress
administration each
dollar invested by the county was
matched by six federal funds the largest
WPA project in the state at the
time the project was completed in
1937 and the area quickly became the
mecca for skiing in New
England at that time it was owned by
belnap county and operated as an indep
dependent Financial entity but in
1959 all that
changed we here in bellnap call it the
enabling statue whereby it created the
Gunstock area commission a board of five
members serving five term fiveyear terms
and this still exists
today in
1986 a huge expansion to revitalize
Gunstock began and by the turn of the
this Century the future of Gunstock was
in
doubt the cost ran to two 10.5 million
with just
65% of the work
completed the options on the table at
that time were to close the
operations lease the mountain to a third
party or keep the mountain
open even if we lease the mountain
belnap County tax pay payers would need
to assume the
debt between
2001 and
2010 when the debt was retired Gunstock
paid $2.4
million and the county taxpayers had
paid $6.2
million overall I am really glad that
that decision was made because we and
belnet County paid for that treasure and
it is a treasure of our County
so the question is who owns
Gunstock according to chapter 399 it is
owned by the county of bellnap and is
incorporated as a body politic and as an
agency of the county of
bellnap I hope this clears up any
questions regarding the ownership of the
mountain now to some statements that
have been made one claimed a forensic
audit would be an unfunded
mandate that is not true it would not
affect the monies that go to bnap County
it would just be a business expense to
say that this expense will cost $50,000
once every five years is also not true
when I contacted a CPA firm that
conducts forensic audits for
governmental agencies they state it can
cost as little as
$5,000 it would only go up if they need
to expand their search because initial
inquire inquiries rais more
questions even if $50,000 every five
years that equates to $110,000 a year a
small sum to assure a $20 million in
annual gross income is being properly
accounted
for if you think this is not political
it really is I once spoke about having a
forensic audit at the county level and
you would have thought I accused someone
of
wrongdoing this is not the purpose of a
forensic audit it is to assure the
taxpayers that everything is above board
and to keep honest people
honest the next time we spoke about
forming an audit committee at the county
level and they preferred a forensic
audit just like I'm asking for
today so let's get to why a forensic
audit is truly
needed I was appointed to the audit
Committee of Gunstock in June of
2022 management was
outraged simply at the idea of an audit
committee the committee lasted for about
four weeks before the other
Commissioners along with General
management coming back to work disbanded
it just as quickly as it got started why
they said that the over $20 million
entity was too small to have an audit
committee think about
that no audit commit committee with
Revenue in excess of $20 million
annually as someone who has been
involved in audits both here in the US
and internationally both public and
private I can tell you that the annual
audit is limited to the information that
the companies or entities provide and
cannot assure that there is no fraud it
actually says this in the audit report
for Gunstock and I am going to quote the
last line of the required supplementary
in statement from the audit report of
August
2023 we do not express an opinion or
provide any Assurance on the information
because the limited procedures do not
provide us with sufficient evidence to
express an opinion or provide any in
assurance that is in the audit report
that is open to the public that anybody
can go and look
at
so what did I learn in this brief time
on the audit
committee I learned that the Gunstock
checking account had to be closed and
reopened under a new account number when
the bank fortunately caught an attempt
to fraudulently cash a check in almost
$100,000 you would think that that
incident would have been reported to the
Gunstock Commissioners so that they
could consider implementing additional
security measures instead they were were
kept in the
dark the next issue concerned the
general manager and CFO as they are the
only signers of the checks with only one
signature needed no matter the dollar
amount the auditor had stated that he
had asked for background information on
the CFO his firm could not find anything
on the internet when they did a search
about
her what did they say and I quote she
has the intelligence to both commit and
conceal this statement is very
disturbing they then went on to discuss
that they regularly did not receive all
the information asked for and that she
was attempting to consolidate accounting
functions to give her greater
control the auditor summarized his
concerns and I quote there is a reason
why you want to slow down the transfer
of
money again as I said a forensic audit
keeps honest people honest
for me the most disturbing information
uncovered in my short time on the audit
committee were three checks in the
amount of $100 in consecutive order
written on the same day that were made
out to the Gunstock area commission it
sounds like no big deal until we
realized they were all drawn from One
Bank cashed at another bank with no
endorsement again I repeat no
endorsement of of any kind and no
signature we have no idea who cashed
these checks or what happened to the
money these checks would never be looked
at under the current annual audit as the
amounts do not ex meet the threshold of
say
$5,000 it is not the job of the CPA our
annual auditing firm to look for these
concerning types of issues or the
political contributions that we were
made aware of and we've all heard
of because those were brought to us by a
private citizen this is why I asking you
to please vote against the itl so that
the floor amendment can be brought
forward please help us ensure that over
$20 million in annual revenue at Gunstar
are being properly spent and Mr Speaker
you for what reason does a member rise I
would like to make a motion State your
motion I would like to table HB 1414 and
motion representative Perez has asked
not will be a division vote
seats
we
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1414 this is going to be a division
vote chair recognized representative Jim
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that the state of New
Hampshire deserves transparency when we
know there's
been obvious mistakes made then would I
now vote to overturn this table so that
made the motion before us to table House
Bill 1414 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos you press a red
seconds
[Music]
represent
O'Brian all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote
45 voting a 329 voting a the motion
fails chair recognizes representative
Tim
kahill thank you Mr speaker friends
colleagues this bill isn't about
politics this bill is about transparency
in government and and when we when when
mistakes are made we have an
obligation to allow transparency so that
things can can be looked at and a light
can be shined on it um I I just I urge
you guys to overturn this itl so that an
amend amendment can be made um to to
look and have transparency on this issue
this isn't about politics this is about
government oversight and the people of
New Hampshire want government oversight
they want transparency so uh I'm asking
itl for what reason the most re mise Mr
Speaker I would move in definite
postponement on House Bill
order representative full has requested
roll calls that sufficiently seconded it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
seats
e
the motion before us is inde deply
postponed members have under me in their
seats the motion before us is inde deply
postponed House Bill
1414 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed CL you press a red
seconds
[Music]
Ed all members present and an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 230 voting a 143 voting a house
postponed
committee on Election to which was
committee on Election law to which was
referred House Bill 1099 relative to
partisan School District elections comes
without
recommendation representative Barry off
moves ought to
pass bills open on second reading open
to further Amendment representative
power moves floor
amendment
96h in your seat
pockets
amendment
amendment put the amendment up please
96 put the amendment
up
1196 be a division's do a
am do you need to do a pi against the
four
all right the motion before us is floor
Amendment 1196 this is going to be a
division
seats
yes
all right the motion before us is the
floor Amendment 11
196 this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes representative Brandon
thank you Mr Speaker if I know this
amendment takes an already complicated
Bill and makes it even more complicated
and if I know that this amendment
continues to make a bad Bill worse by
making it operationally unworkable would
I now press the red button to defeat the
amendment thank you chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker fellow
colleagues
if you would kindly press the green
button for the amendment to just clarify
a few I'm sorry if I know that the uh
Amendment just clarifies a few ter terms
within the proposed bill would I now
press the green button to adopt the
amendment motion before us is floor
Amendment 11 196 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
represent
syes all members present had opportunity
to vote house will attend to say to the
vote
187 voting a 186 voting a the amendment
is
adopted now we're on to Auto pass as
amended it's been request for request
for a division members stay in your
seats this will be a division
vote everybody in the room everybody is
in the room we're moving right to the
vote chair recognizes representative
Brenan for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know this bill would
Institute an overly complicated process
in our traditionally non-partisan
Community focused elections that are
already challenging enough to find
candidates willing to run in such a
politically hostile time if I know this
bill as amended is operationally
unworkable particularly for school
districts that comprise multiple towns
introducing confusing terms and offices
that do not otherwise exist in New
Hampshire election law and Mr Speaker if
I know we have heard from our
constituents that they are tired of
hyperarid rhetoric seeping into our
traditional nonpartisan local elections
would I now press the red button so
another motion may be made thank
you you recognized represent worry for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker fellow
Representatives if I know that this
enabling legislation as amended would
allow a school district to adopt a
partisan ballot in their election but
only if that school district chooses to
do so and if I know that this
legislation is strikingly similar to the
enabling statute of RSA
6692 which allows the option of partisan
Town elections and if I know that having
the candidates party affiliation readily
available would help to inform the
voters in that school district election
and if I know that having more
information about the candidates May
dispel any lingering reluctance to
participate and could actually increase
voter interest in turnout and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that a New Hampshire
voter if that voter was familiar with a
well-known song by Leslie Gore that upon
seeing the candidates party affiliation
so clearly listed in that ballot the
voter th then might Rejoice at that
recognition and cry out it's my party
and I'll vote how I want to I'll vote
how I want to I'll vote how I want you
would I now press the green button in
motion the motion before us is auto as
amended on House Bill 1099 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're oppose
you press a red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
representative
hary
all members pres had an opportunity to
vote
how while members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
say to the
vote
185 voting a 188 voting a the motion
fails representative Brennan moves in
expedient to
legislate for what reason does a member
rise I move to table House Bill
order division has been
requested members stay in your seats or
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
1099 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
represent
bber
all members present have an opportunity
vote 188 voting a 186 phon n 10 House
table
majority of the committee on Election
law to which was referred House Bill
1119 act relative to absentee ballots
having considered the same report the
same with a following Amendment
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen Ross Berry for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to to legislate sen Caitlyn
katab for the minority of the committee
the amendment is 0767 H printed in house
record 11 pages 47- 49 are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say I I those oppose nay the
eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted this is going to be a division
vote and we have two Pi we have piis
only so members take your seats this
will be a division
vote
is
that press the roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
vote
yes
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended in House Bill
119 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative katab for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that part one article 11 of
the New Hampshire Constitution
explicitly authorizes the legisl
to provide for absentee voting for only
two reasons one physical disability and
two absence from the town or
city if I know that expanding the
absentee voter affidavit to include
absence because of snowstorms exceeds
the authority of the Constitution and is
therefore not permissive legislative
judgment if I know that this very matter
is currently awaiting adjudication in
the New Hampshire Supreme Court and
finally Mr Speaker if I know that the
only proper way to make this change is
by cacr would I now press the red
button J recognize representative Lane
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill amends an existing
statute that was passed in
2018 uh to address a situation where
many Town moderator ERS cancelled
elections due to a severe winter storm
which created a great curfuffle between
the towns and the Secretary of State and
if I know that the existing statute was
worked as a bar bipartisan effort and if
I know that the bill only applies when
there's a snowstorm on town meeting day
and if I know that this bill does not
change any substantive portions of the
bill all it does is simplify the form
that is called for by the bill and if I
know that if the case discussed by my
colleague from wendham is decided for
the plff then it will override the
statute regardless of what happens here
today then would I press the green
button to support the 19 to1 bipartisan
vote of the election law committee to
pass this Bill thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority committee report of autop pass
as amended on House Bill
1119 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're oppose you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent represent
Bui
well members present and an opportunity
to vote house attend to stay to the
vote 282 voting a 92 voting a committee
adopted
committee on Election lot to which was
referred House Bill 1147 relative to
permissible campaign contributions by
business organizations and labor unions
comes without
recommendation representative Hamlet
move moves ought to
pass office floor Amendment uh Amendment
0638 H printed in house record 11 page
50 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose
nay you eyes have it and the amendment
is
adopted for what reason does a member
rise uh yes Mr Speaker I move in
definite postponement on House Bill
that is a correct motion so the motion
before us is indefinitely postponed
1147 a division has been requested
seats
for
the motion before us is inde definitely
postponement for House Bill
1147 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Reed for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that when the New Hampshire
Supreme Court struck down our the
legislative body's campaign Finance law
that they left us in a situ ation where
we inadvertently treat corporations and
unions differently in campaign finance
and if I know that the Supreme Court
when they struck down that law gave us
very explicit instructions on how to
remedy the situation by applying the
same language to both unions and
corporations equally and if I know that
this bill does exactly what the New
Hampshire Supreme Court instructed us to
do by applying the same language to both
unions and corporations so that we
fulfill the original intent of our 19177
campaign Finance law then Mr Speaker
would I now press the red button against
indefinite postponement so that we can
fulfill our duty and create an even
playing
field here recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill extends the current restriction on
political donations by labor unions to
all business organizations and this
restriction is partly due because of the
forced um workers joining unions and
paying dues a situation that does not
stand for corporations and makes them on
a different playing field when it comes
to collecting money and finally Mr
Speaker if I am concerned that this
would make it more difficult for a small
business corporation that is the
foundation of New Hampshire to
participate fairly in these elections
would I press the green button now for
for a postpone it thank you motion
before us is definitely postponed House
Bill 11 147 this is a going to be a
division
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed you'll
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e
all members present had an opportunity
vote 187 voting aay 186 voting aay post
ponent
passes
committee on Election law to which was
referred House
Bill 1149 relative to doile residency
voter registration investigation of
voter verification letters relative to
the terms resident inhabitant residency
and
residency this comes without
recommendation representative Lane moves
ought to
pass and requests a division
vote for what reason does a member rise
uh yes Mr Speaker uh I would make the
motion uh to indefinitely postpone House
Bill
1149 that is a correct motion
representative Sweeney has asked for a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
vote
the motion be Force to a definitely
postpone House Bill
1149 this is a roll call
vote chair recognize representative
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I know
if I know that this bill would take us
backwards in time to a time when you
could show up to any polling location in
the state of New Hampshire present
nothing register to vote and be handed a
ballot and and Mr Speaker if I know that
that system causes um concerns about the
Integrity of our electoral process would
I now press the green button to support
the indefinite postponement
motion CH recognize representative Ward
Cory thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that this
bill restores
uh important sections and definitions of
our voting laws back to the way as we
just heard that they were for decades
for decades before all the recent
needless
restrictions and if I know that these
unnecessary constraints from the last
few years are especially detrimental and
harmful to Young Voters student voters
old voters highly mobile voters and
homeless voters to say nothing of
forgetful voters and if I also know that
I'm more interested in our citizens
exercising their right to vote than I am
in throwing up roadbox and regulations
aimed at turning away eligible voters
from both parties but I then press the
red button to defeat this motion so we
can actually vote on the bill thank you
Mr
Speaker the motion before us is
inexpedient it is inde definitely
postpone House Bill 1149 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to state of
the
vote 190 voting a 84 voting a house bill
postponed committee on Election law to
which was referred House Bill 1264 FN in
act relative to the definition of
accessible voting systems having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill Auto pass with
Amendment repr Robert wary for the
committee the amendment is 10418 P
printed in house record 11 page 52 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes haven't the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted
ch
the committee on Election law to which
is referred House Bill 1523 revising the
moderator's worksheet for counting votes
and elections comes to us without
recommendation representative Burnham
moves off to pass and offers Amendment
H printed in house record 11 on page
62 this will be a division vote on the
seats
the questions on Amendment
1053 H representative haml recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker I apologize
I'm confused on what amendment we are
talking
about which amendment are
you
1053 okay then I have to wave up all
righty sure
representative Burnham's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry oh you guys were on 12:25 yeah
aor
please
am
left moving on the question is on B the
Burnham floor Amendment 1225 H which is
pockets and this time we're going
straight to a division and there might
be pis we in division going to are you
do
a all right we're still doing a division
vote representative Lan's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry if I know that this
amendment is essentially the same as the
underlying bill and if I know that the
underlying bill is unnecessary and
confusing and if I know there's already
enough that we have laid at the on the
backs of our moderators and clerks then
would I vote against this bill against
the amendment
sorry representative Burnham's
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues if I know this bill has been
accomplished by other legislation
recently approved by the governor and
that this floor Amendment Narrows the
focus to address one item missed by the
already approved
legislation absentee ballot
accountability and if I know absente
ballot accountability is nothing more
than a good business practice of
inventory accountability which is simply
know knowing the number of absentee
ballots that you start with and the
number of absentee ballots that you have
at the end of the election then would I
press the green button to pass this
all right so the question is the
adoption of amendment
1225 H and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
seconds
[Music]
Reed
well uh have have all members presents
had an opportunity to vote okay and
you're all attending to the state of the
fails the question is now on ought to
pass is also a division vote as a
Pro we will proceed with the division
vote right now representative Hamlet
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that the
supervisors of the checklists in the
cities and towns keep accurate and
retrievable records of the absentee
ballot inventory in election net and if
I know that adding the absentee ballot
inventory to the pre-election
certificate would conflict with the
purpose of that certificate and cause
confusion and if I know there would be a
better way to report the absentee ballot
inventory to a voter who wants to see
the whole inventory process from
beginning to end and if I know that this
bill would also add the absentee ballot
inventory to the Post elction certific
ific which was formerly the moderator
certificate that was recently renamed by
154 um so which would make the post
elction certificate even more
complicated than it already is would I
then press the red button to defeat this
a to pass as amended motion ought to
Speaker representative Burnham's
colleagues if I know that the recently
approved legislation now keeps better
track of the election day ballots and
and this bill would allow New Hampshire
to keep a better track of absentee
ballots at the same level of
accountability as election day ballots
and if I know that business is whether a
corporate giant or a local mom and pop
store must know all their inventory to
stay in business and if I know that good
business sense and Common Sense tells us
to keep track of all inventory not just
some of it and if I know that absentee
ballot accountability is applying good
business sense of inventory control to
New Hampshire
elections and if I know
that better ballot accountability means
better election
transparency and better election
transparency means higher voter
confidence and election Integrity in New
Hampshire then I would press the green
button for a to pass motion thank
you the questions on the motion of a to
pass on House Bill 1523 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button button opposed press
seconds
[Music]
have all members presence I an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 185 and the affirmative 188 and the
fails representative Hamlet moves in
expedient to legislate are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppos nay no
adopted the majority of the committee on
environment and agriculture to which was
referred House Bill
1351 an act prohibiting the sale and use
of adhes iive based rodent traps having
considered the same report same with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative Linda H
Haskins for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Barbara Kat from the
minority of the
committee the question is on the
majority committee report of inim study
representative Comas would recognized to
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues rodents no matter how cute
you think they are they're a public
health issue did you know that rodent
spread disease diseases that can be
spread to people directly or indirectly
from
them they can actually spread over 200
diseases
indirect spread of disease can be when a
flea mosquito might or tick feed on an
infected
rodent and I know that we don't have any
mosquitoes or ticks in New Hampshire or
should I say which one do we have more
of yes the member will suspend for a
minute I know um all of you seem to have
some place to go and that's fine but if
you could get there quietly that would
be more respectful to the person
speaking continue thank you uh yes we
can use Bay traps but if you have ever
had a decomposing rodent carcass in your
walls the odor is not only offensive it
could also be associated with bacteria
and something as dangerous as a
potentially H antivirus and I say deadly
between 1993 and
2021 we had one person actually die here
in New Hampshire from the virus and
there are many other health issues that
may go undos undiagnosed from rodent
diseases in truth we need all the tools
to com combat infestations of rodents in
our homes barns stores factories
Etc one female Mouse can have as many as
year that is just one female Mouse think
about that you will need to compound
that effect for every female Mouse in
that litter breeding every 19 to 21 days
they be can become pregnant at four
weeks of age and a house mouse can live
up to two
years we do not need to study this issue
we need to have all the tools available
to us these adhesive traps will not work
outside when dirt or dust get on the
adhesive and as a matter of fact I don't
know of anyone who uses them outside
without having a shelter shelter over
them and since I have
dogs I have concerns about my animals
ingesting erodents who die because of
the bait if this occurs my dogs could
become very seriously
ill in conclusion I believe it is
sensible to let the market dictate what
is
necessary as this truly is a public
health
issue representative H Haskins is
report thank you Mr Speaker the
environment and agriculture committee
heard testimony on this bill to prohibit
adhesive based traps commonly called
glue
traps from those who use them for rodent
removal and those who oppose them
opposition to these traps includes the
CDC
the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department the US fish and wildlife
service and the American Veterinary
Medical Association among multiple
wildlife rehab centers throughout the
state particularly persuasive was the
acknowledgment that these traps often in
snare innocent
animals and birds including song birds
squirrels even
cats when an animal is caught in a glue
trap they face a slow and extremely
painful death until they die by
starvation in a panic to escape they
often rip off patches of skin fur and
even chew off body body parts in a vain
attempt to free themselves
we believe that the adhesive strips that
we've all seen used for insects are
exempt from this
category in recognition of the need for
rodent control on behalf of professional
exterminators as well as farmers and
homeowners the majority feels this issue
needs further study to determine whether
other 21st century solutions to Pest
Control need not include this grossly
inhumane remedy please vote with a
bipartisan majority and press the green
button for interim study thank you and I
vote all right the questions on the
majority committee report of inim study
and the will be a division vote members
seats
e
questions on the majority committee
report of inum study on House Bill
1351 representative kon's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that HB 1351 limits
consumer Choice with regard to Pest
Control if I know that adhesive pest
strips provide an effective non-chemical
option to protect families from rodent
infestation and if I also know that the
New Hampshire Department of Agriculture
and the Farm Bureau are opposed to this
legislation would I not press the red
button so that another more appropriate
motion could be made thank
you representative Bosman is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that
multiple expert organizations oppose
glue traps including the CDC the New
Hampshire Fish and Game department the
US fish and wildlife service and the
American Veterinary Medical Association
as well as multiple Wildlife
rehabilitation centers throughout the
state of New Hampshire and if I know
that death by Glue trap is a horrible
torturous and inhumane death and that
not only the rodents intended for the
traps are subject subject to this death
but also many other beloved animals
including wildlife and domesticated pets
and Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
needs to be modified to allow the use of
insect glue strips and to consider
options outside of glue traps that
deserve attention no knowing that it is
2024 and many options exist would I now
press the green button to support an
interim
study thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of inum study and House
Bill 1351 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
seconds
[Music]
am
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend of
the state of the vote 191 in the
affirmative 169 in the negative the
adopted the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
is referred House Bill
1335 an act removing Columbus Day as a
holiday having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Matthew Simon for the committee the
questions on the majority report of
inexpedient to legislate you ready for
the
question representative will request a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded yeah that's 10 this will be a
seats
the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1335 representative Horgan is recognized
order thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know that the creation of
the Columbus Day holiday which wasn't
officially established in 1968 may have
made some sense in
1968 but if I also know they given what
we know about Columbus now in
24 um he's not an appropriate person the
name of holiday after and I mean no dis
disrespect to either the Italian people
or the Spanish people both of whom
consider them one of theirs and if I
also know that the that when it was
established part of it was the
uh was ATT tribute to the idea of
Discovery but Columbus didn't really
discover anything there were millions of
people already Living in
America when he came over here though
not to anything is now part of the
so if I know that he didn't discover
America anyway he was not even the first
European to visit America would I
then you knew that was coming if I so if
I know all these things all these
rhetorical questions I just asked you
would I now press the red button for the
itl motion so that uh another motion can
be considered thank
you representative Carol Maguire is
inquiry thank you Mr Mr Speaker if I
know that Columbus Day is a vitally
important holiday between Labor Day and
Thanksgiving and if I know that it has
been adopted by Italian Americans as a
symbol of their importance to this to
the country and if I know that Columbus
regardless of any personal failure ings
did in fact accomplish a truly
major event that is the connection of
the western and the Eastern hemispheres
would I now press the green button to
decision the questions on the M majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislate on ill 1335 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppose press the red voting
e
Greg have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 331 in the affirmative 42 in the
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which is referred House Bill 1411 FN an
act relative to requiring agencies and
their contractors to accept cash
payments having consider the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate represent ative Jack groa for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Carol Brown from the
minority of the
committee representative Comm recognized
report thank you Mr
chair oh Mi Mr Speaker I do apologize my
mind is somewhere else today obviously
um but my sincerest apologies Mr Speaker
um anyways uh I Rise before you to
overturn the itl um there is a floor
amendment that addresses one of the
issues in the bill about uh the Spalding
Turnpike um and what this Bill is saying
is that state
agencies contractors subcontractors must
accept cash at all transaction
points that includes the toll
system and I think it's
important we have citizens in this state
that travel our roadways that cannot
afford a
transponder and
need the cash Lane to go
through um when we
force citizens to have to have this
transponder we are alienating a good
portion of our our
population and unfortunately with the
Easy Pass uh transponder you have to
keep a minimum balance which really
harms some of the people in New
Hampshire so I would ask that you
overturn the itl so that the floor
Amendment could be brought thank
you representative mcart is recognized
report
okay how about representative groda you
go
good afternoon Mr
Speaker when the committee received this
bill and during the hearing we
considered it a serious
matter because indeed not everyone has
access to a credit card not everyone has
the cash available for that or checking
account
so one of the committee members the one
who's speaking now called the
commissioner of the Department of
administrative services and asked what
state agency does not accept cash
because we have a bill here
that
will mandate that state agencies take
cash and their answer was that cash is a
way of transacting business in the state
of New Hampshire in all agencies if you
go to the Department of Motor Vehicles
you can pay for your driver's license
with cash even if you want to um go to
the tool booth and you don't have the
cash you can get a non-traceable
transponder and pay for that transponder
with cash so I hope that you will
consider the committee's recommendation
to support
itl and recognize that this is a
difficult situation for many in for some
okay and I ask for division
vote the questions on the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislate and this will be a division
seats
e
questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1411 representative Carol
inquiry
uh thank you Mr Speaker I I apologize if
I'm going to be a little bit repetitious
it's likely if Mr Speaker if I know that
it's very likely that no one in this
room has to face the situation where
they don't have a bank account they
don't have a checkbook and therefore
they don't have a debit card or a credit
card and you can pay your bills in any
way that anyone
asks and if I and that there are many
citizens of New Hampshire who are in
that boat and Mr Speaker if I know that
these people may not even have the extra
money to go purchase money orders as was
as was suggested during Committee
hearing why don't they just get a money
order they may not have the money to do
that I know that sounds kind of crazy to
all of
us and Mr Speaker if I know that as was
mentioned
already the toll boost on the Spalding
turpike was a point of contention in the
committee hearings and that if we move
from this itl there is an amendment that
takes care of that
issue and finally Mr Speaker lastly and
interestingly enough as it came out in
the committee there are definitely also
people in the room who would like to pay
cash regardless of whether they have a
bank account or not that's their
preference and finally Mr Speaker
understanding as my colleague said
before
me it has been reported that the state
agencies do take
cash that the sponsor of the bill and
those
supporting suggests that it's important
to maintain that through the future
because the way of life and the way we
pay is changing so
quickly in that case I would press uh
you somebody will tell them
representative Carol McGuire's Rec
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that every state agency from every state
that's ever existed is delighted to take
your
money and if I know that every state
agency does in fact take cash and is
glad to and if I know there are at least
three legal ways to avoid to avoid
needing a transponder or paying a fee
Beyond on the toll on the Spalding
turnpike would I not press the green
button and support the committee
decision questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1411 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 306 in the affirmative 63 and the
adopted
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 1347 an
act relative to administration of the
New Hampshire Refugee settlement program
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative Jim kofalt for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
major Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Joe Shapiro for the minority of the
committee questions on the majority
committee report of inum study you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose nay the eyes have
adopted
the majority of the committee on Health
Human Services and elderly Affairs to
which referred House Bill 1683 FN an act
relative to coverage of circumcision
under the State Medicaid plan having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Erica
Lon for the majority of the committee
the amendment is
0573 printed on house record 11 on Page
6 7 the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Joe Shapiro for the majority of the
committee the questions on adoption of
amendment 0573 H are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay no all right the eyes
the eyes have a valiant effort the eyes
have it and the Amendments adopted
the question now is the main motion of
ought to pass as
amended
representative representative Wayne
McDonald's recognized to speak for the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker the Medicaid Program
its appropriation implementation and
coverage Provisions have been a major
topic of conversation in this
chamber as we all well remember the
debate in committees and on this house
floor about its seven-year expansion
involved a great deal of
discussion medical coverage for those in
need is indeed an important matter and
deserves our
attention however the Medicaid Program
is about procedures and treatment that
are medically necessary and circumcision
is not always such a
procedure the majority respects those
who believe in the procedure being
performed whether it be for religious or
other reasons the purpose of this bill
is not to ban it
altogether Mr Speaker and colleagues I
ask that you press the green button and
support the bipartisan majority
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended thank you Mr
speaker representative Shapiro's
report thank you Mr
Speaker of all the things that I thought
I never would do before I joined the
legislature making a speech about
circumcision to 400 of my peers probably
tops the
list nevertheless here I am asking you
to oppose HB 1190 a bill that would end
coverage in the Medicaid Program for
routine circumcision of male
infants currently New Hampshire Medicaid
reimburses for circumcision at B at
Birth as an elective procedure it is not
considered cosmetic because there is
ample research showing potential medical
benefits such as reduction in penile
Cancers and reduced rates of HIV
transmission it is also not considered
an urgent required procedure it is
elective it is a choice a parental
choice and I am here today to ask you
not to take that parental choice that
parental prerogative dare I say that
parental right
away passing this bill would be an
intrusion into the freedom of New
Hampshire parents to make medical
decisions for their
families using Medicaid as a tool this
bill will legislate the practice
medicine something we try to avoid in
health health human services and elderly
Affairs one time it might be something
you
value sometimes it's something that your
adversary values the reality is there's
no end that's why we try to keep Health
Care decisions between patients and
providers this bill fails that
test perhaps the most important reason
to oppose HB
1190 is the issue of Health care Equity
passage of this bill will allow wealthy
people or people with Private health
insurance to make a choice about
circumcision unencumbered by Financial
concerns while lowincome Granite Staters
including lowincome Muslim and Jewish
granted Staters will have to consider
the financial consequences of their
decision now I know that some of you
will say that the amendment to this bill
will allow ow for broad doctor
discretion and ironically that a bill
that intends to prohibit reimbursement
for routine male infant circumcision
will actually allow it if a health care
provider deems it medically
necessary this however is just not the
case the attorney for the Medicaid
Program at DHHS informs me that as
written the amendment is not even apply
to infants and in no way clarifies what
will be covered and what will not be
covered
some testify that parents at a
vulnerable moment having just given
birth are unprepared to make a decision
about circumcision that more education
is needed a fair and balanced
presentation of the pros and cons of
circumcision I totally agree unlike when
my kids were born virtually every parent
knows the sex of their child early on in
pregnancy and in fact anti- circum ision
activists have been very very successful
in this regard rates of male
circumcision have dropped dramatically
over the past three
decades in wrapping up I would ask you
to put aside any personal feelings you
might have about
circumcision some of you clearly have
very strong feelings about it and some
like myself thought about it for a short
period before their children were born
in my case I ended up having two
daughters
and then didn't give it much thought
until now there is no right or wrong
decision about male circumcision it is a
deeply personal decision and should be
made with adequate information and with
counsel from Family Medical providers
and clergy if res if relevant please
push the red button to De defeat the
otpa motion so that another motion can
be made and medical freedom can be
preserved thank you and I would request
vote representative Phillips is
question thank you Mr Speaker hello
everyone the state is spending over
$100,000 a year in billing codes paying
for medically unnecessary non
therapeutic elective surgeries namely
infant
circumcisions this does not include fees
for providers supplies facilities in the
11% revision rate where children return
for corrective procedures after botch
jobs across our nation 18 states have
eliminated Medicaid coverage for infant
circumcisions since 1996 infant
circumcisions have have been have not
been publicly insured service through
Canada or the UK UK the decision to
drops coverage in these states has
always been based on the lack of valid
medical indications for the procedure
routine circumcision is not recommended
by any national medical organization in
the world the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services have defined
circumcision performed at parental
request as elective surgery the United
States Congress appropriates Medicaid
funds to states only for medically
necessary
Services social cultural religious and
ethnic Traditions are the primary
factors and not MediCal ones that
parents site when making the decision to
circumcise their newborn
Sons the American Academy of Pediatrics
and the American Medical Association
have declined to recommend it as a
routine
practice as a result the national circum
circumcision rates have now dropped to
55% this is evidence that this surgery
is not an essential component of newborn
care when nearly half of today's parents
are not choosing circumcision it can no
longer be defended as the standard of
care in the United States or New
Hampshire Medicaid funding coverage
implies an endorsement of routine
circumcision when no such endorsement
actually exists in New Hampshire why
would a young and un uninformed parent
declined to accept something ordered
offered by a doctor for
free why would a doctor not recommend it
when he is certain to get Medicaid
reimbursement for the
service circumcision is the only surgery
performed on children without a
diagnosis and it is the most common one
performed on them circumcision performed
at parental request is something other
than medicine and it cannot stand up to
the objective budget scrutiny because it
cannot meet Medicaid's criteria of
medically necessary please vote green
representative boschman has recognized
report thank you Mr speaker thank you
everybody my name is Paige bman and I
have been a registered Women's Health
and psychiatric nurse for nearly 15
years I'm a child birth and newborn care
educator and an expert in maternal
mental health I'm also the nurse in the
hospital who whether I love it or not my
job is to bring the baby to the doctor
to be
circumcised I come to you today with
that experience urging you to oppose
this bill even though the amendment
passed first I'd like to say I truly
appreciate my colleague across the aisle
the underlying intent of this bill is
right on the money we desperately need
better public health education about the
the risks of circumcision de ision in
fact I myself have spent my career
educating families so that they can make
a truly informed decision this is why I
can't see right now uh so that they can
make a truly informed decision about
circumcising or not circumcising their
babies my primary concern with this
particular bill is that it does not take
into account that currently most parents
in New Hampshire specifically expect to
circumcise their son and this bill will
suddenly and unexpectedly have that
option stripped from them without
warning I worry how an Abrupt ban will
impact parents and Health Care Systems
who were unprepared for a change like
this a better option for addressing the
prevalence of unnecessary circumcision
would be to improve public health
education instead of just Banning it as
a clinici I am fully aware circumcision
is not medically necessary but
unfortunately it's not just that cut and
dry I sorry the fact remains that the
topic
has the topic has been debated for years
and even now as we started debating in
our own bodies many Health Care
Professionals are still unclear about
whether or not circumcision is medically
necessary or not and the majority of
people in New Hampshire either still
believe that circum decision is
medically necessary or at the very least
and this is from my experience working
with them it's a very deeply invested
cultural norm and it's important to them
and their identity if many Healthcare
Providers don't even have the accurate
information how are parents supposed to
get the correct information now we heard
a statistic that circumcision is down to
about
55% that's true but that's a national
figure in New Hampshire
76% of boys get circumcised and in other
states it's down to 10 to 50% based on a
really great job at public education so
it really is when we're looking at 76%
it's realistic to say that when most
parents in New Hampshire go to have
their baby they're assuming that they
will circumcise their son and that they
will have that option now for just a
minute if any of you were parents think
back to the first day you held that
newborn baby in your arms how you might
have been scared about what kind of
parent you were going to be how you
desperately wanted to do everything you
could possibly do to take care of your
baby in the best way that you knew how
and anybody's a parent knows you didn't
know how but you learned now imagine
that the nurse told you that the care
that you believed your baby needed would
not be available to you because of your
low income because that's what I'm going
to have to say to people people in the
room with them if we pass this right now
how would that have affected you in that
moment exhausted and just learning how
to be a new parent how would it have
affected your
selfworth these are the kinds of moments
that stick with people for a lifetime
and can have long-term impacts on
maternal mental health the birth and
immediate postpartum experience
significantly impact the risk of
postpartum mental health issues and I
fear that suddenly Banning circumcisions
could have detrimental effects on many
of our mothers especially those with
Medicaid coverage who are already often
at a higher risk for mental health
conditions some of you might brush off
this idea but having interviewed
thousands of pregnant and postpartum
women about their stories of birth
trauma and Associated postpartum
depression and anxiety I can assure you
this is a sincere
concern it's true we should absolutely
work as a bipartisan body to decrease
unnecessary circumcisions in the state
of New Hampshire but Banning it only for
the granite Staters who are lowincome
doesn't even address the problem of
misinformation about circumcision and it
has a more potential to it has a
potential to do more harm than good I
suggest that instead we start with a
robust Health excuse me Public Health
campaign and work towards bringing those
circumcision numbers down organically
like so many other states have done
let's take the time to explore other
options more closely along with healthc
Care Professionals so that we can
develop a solution that relies on
education and collaboration instead of
force thank you does a member yield for
a
you re pres Ellen re's recognized to
speak in support of the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker um this
won't be a surprise to anyone I don't
think but I'm a huge proponent of
socialized Health Care uh a huge
proponent but circumcision medically
unnecessary circumcision on infant boys
is the only elective caus medic
medically unnecessary procedure that we
spend taxpayer money on
it's also the only
cultural and the only religious-based
procedure that we spend taxpayer money
on now I want to be really clear it's
not a religious procedure as it is done
in the hospital because in order for it
to be a religious procedure it has to be
done in a certain time like eight days
after birth and by a certain clergy
person so that's not what's happening
what's happening is it's become a
cultural norm that we do not
question but we are in effect virtually
the only country that does this
routinely by
default 80% of the men of the world are
not
circumcised and they're doing
okay in fact it's not just we're the
only country human beings are the only
species we claim that it supposedly is
medically necessary to do this at Birth
other species that are born with
foreskin dogs cats horses un it they
fine in fact it's it's purely
cultural
and member will suspend for a minute
noise levels Rising steadily let's
descend it steadily thank you
continue thank you Mr
Speaker one in 16,000 uncircumcised men
end up needing a circumcision for
medical reasons later in life but 11% of
circumcised infants have some form of
complication including the need for
revision
surgeries some of those infants end up
being children that have long- lasting
negative medical impacts from those
complications what it really comes down
to is choice and bodily autonomy and we
talk a lot about those Concepts here now
I know that a previous speaker just said
that this is a parental choice
but it's not a parental Choice when that
child becomes an adult and that choice
has been taken away from them because if
you choose to circumcise your infant
they don't get to choose to be
uncircumcised when they're older if you
don't circumcise then they get to make
older another thing I want to bring up
is the fact that Medicade does not cover
female genital mutilation now here's the
thing about that before you say well
that's different some of it is very very
different some forms of female genital
mutilation are extremely severe however
the most common form in the world is
analogous exactly to circumcision it is
the removal of the clitoral hood we do
not cover that with taxpayer money also
it's illegal to do it at all on a female
child in this
country so female infants have
protections that not only do we not
extent to extend to male infants we
actually pay for those male infants to
have healthy tissue removed from Healthy
Babies healthy tissue removed from
Healthy
Babies the truth of the matter is I'm a
strong proponent of socialized medicine
so I believe that the money that's being
spent removing healthy tissue from
Healthy Babies should be spent on
medically necessary treatment for
children now I appreciate the previous
speaker who wanted to um make a point
about the access for the poor to this um
to this
procedure but we would never want to
increase access for the removal of the
clitoral hood for example we wouldn't
want to increase access for that 17
states do not use Medicaid funds to
cover unnecessary circumcision and the
sky is not falling in those States
there's no trauma to to parents in those
States there's no discrimination in
those
States and in fact the wealthy around
the world as far as men go tend to be
uncircumcised so it's not really an
issue of poverty versus money it's an
issue of right and wrong and how we
treat newborn baby boys and with that
thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
1683 you ready for the question yeah I
thought so this will be a division vote
seats
e
the questions in the majority committee
report of ought to pass is amended on
House Bill
1683 representative Shapiro was
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that one's vote on this bill
should have nothing to do with one's
personal feelings about
circumcision and Mr Speaker if I know
this bill will intrude upon and diminish
a parents rights to make Health Care
decisions for their children
and Mr Speaker if I know that it is an
insult to New Hampshire citizens to
believe
that citizens will use circumcision
merely because it's free and or doctors
will do circumcisions to make money off
of it and if I know that in the long run
persuasion is more effective than
force would I then urge you Mr Speaker
to push the the red button to defeat
defeat the otpa motion so a new motion
may be made thank
you representative Phillips is
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that Medicaid uses
finite resources to cover only medically
necessary procedures and no Public
Health Organization claims circumcision
is medically necessary and if I know
that in executive hearings we learn that
private insurances such as Anthem do not
cover elective infant
circumcisions and if I know this
legislation has strong bipartisan
support and pass committee with a 146
vote in favor of OTP and lastly Mr
Speaker if I know that forkin is not a
birth defect and nobody wants less penis
would I press the green
button
[Applause]
order I'm just going to wait I'd like to
go home real bad but I'm just going to
order
the question is on the majority
committee report of our to pass is
amended on House Bill 1683 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 178 in the affirmative 197 and the
negative the Motions defeated
representative Shapiro moves inexpedient
to legislate for what reason does
representative postpone Russ I would
table
table my bad representative Sweeney
moves that house Bill 1683 be laid on
the table are you ready for that
question and this representative
Phillips requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is this will be
seats
e
all right the question is whether to lay
House Bill 1683 on the table
representative Shapiro's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker
if I know that the majority of this body
whatever their feel personal feelings
are about circumcision believe that
people should have the right to make
their own decisions for their own
families and if I know Mr
Speaker that people should do not feel
that there should be further
disparities for lowincome Medicaid
recipients would I then push the red
button so that the tabling motion will
be defeated and we can make a more
you questions whether the lay House Bill
1683 on the table this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote when 8 in the affirmative 187 and
the negative House Bill 1683 is laid on
the
table for what reason does the member
rise to request that the remarks from
the previous debate be put into the
permanent
[Applause]
Journal
with without
ordered
majority of the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill 102 act
relative to fees for records under the
right to no law having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that bill be referred for
interum study pres of Cam Kenny for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee have considered the same
being unable to agree with a majority
Report with the following Amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment sen Caitlyn to for
the minority of the committee the motion
before us is refer for intern study are
you ready for the question no no no no
Kenny speaking against chair recognize
representative
Kenny thank you Mr Speaker um so when I
initially spoke uh to recommit this bill
and then motion for interim study in
exec session was to allow stakeholders
which includes the ACLU New Hampshire
press Association right to know New
Hampshire New Hampshire Municipal
Association and legislators from the
Judiciary Committee to come up with a
compromise uh negotiations never looked
hopeless only that everyone needed more
time to reach an agreement after the
executive session stakeholders and
legislators met for an extended period
and hammered out a compromise that every
interested part interested party was
content with at this point there is no
reason to believe uh that additional
conversation would result in a different
or preferable compromise which is why I
urge my colleagues to vote against the
committee recommendation of interim
study so we can discuss uh the agreed
Speaker
representative kutab has asked for a
seats
for
the motion before us to refer for
interum study
this is a division vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that a few members of the
committee were able to come together
last week to do the work that was
already needed for this study if I know
that we were able to work together with
stakeholders such as right to know New
Hampshire the New Hampshire press
Association the ACLU and nhma to reach a
Balan solution to a complex problem with
a floor Amendment if I know that there
is no more that I could possibly study
on this particular Bill if I know that I
do not want to embark on the Fool's
errand of a study committee for work
that is already complete especially when
I could be enjoying the
beach and Mr Speaker if this motion does
pass please I beg your mercy do not
appoint me to it Mr Speaker please join
me in pressing red and honoring our our
responsibility to our taxpayers thank
you the motion before us is refer for
interm study on House Bill
one2 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend to state
vote 105 voting yay 266 voting nay the
motion
fails
representative couta boobs ought to pass
and offer floor
Amendment
1173 H it is in your seat
pocketses K speak and the chair
Kenny uh thank you Mr Speaker uh so this
floor Amendment satisfies the people
most likely to be involved in right to
no request disputes and solves a number
of problems identified by the New
Hampshire Supreme Court over the past
several years uh such as the lack of
collaboration between requesters and the
government uh like I previously said the
groups involved in these discussions and
compromise include the ACLU New
Hampshire press Association right to
know New Hampshire New Hampshire
Municipal Association and of course
legislators uh from the Judiciary
Committee so the floor Amendment
provides a local option to allow
charging a per electronic communication
charge of up to $1 per page but the
first 250 Communications are always free
electronic communications is defined and
narrowly tailored to Target only the
sources of the largest and most
problematic
requests it provides language to ensure
that those who cannot afford to pay for
requests will not be charged it
specifies that requests in the Public's
interest will not be charged as well and
Define such requests using wording
agreed upon by these
stakeholders it also offers an appeal
process to ensure that public interest
requests are never charged lastly the
language of the floor Amendment still
promotes collaboration between the
government and requesters and it
encourages the use of automated
redaction processes to speed up the
production of Records so in short this B
this is a balanced compromise that
ensures government transparency yet it
deals with right to no requests that are
in bad faith therefore I urge my
colleagues to adopt uh the floor
Amendment 1173 thank you Mr Speaker the
motion before us is floor Amendment 1173
h president of Granger has requested a
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
okay
the motion before us is floor Amendment
1173 H this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're oppos press a red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
all members present have an opportunity
vote 3 45 voting a 24 voting a floor
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass unamended representative
Granger has asked for a roll call is
that sufficiently
vote
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
10002 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
seconds
[Music]
repr
representative
Perez all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 268 voting yay 106 voting nay
adopted for what reason is a member rise
thank you Mr Speaker having voted on the
pre prevailing side I move to reconsider
no the question before us is on
reconsideration on House Bill
10002 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I those oppose
defe committee on Judiciary to which is
referred House Bill 1082 an act relative
to professional limited liability
company PLL LLC assistant manager status
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment sen of Eric tur for the
committee the amendment is
1060 printed in house record 11 page 46
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
oppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted majority of the committee on
Judiciary to which is referred House
Bill 111 five act relative to
determination of tency at the expiration
of the tency or lease term consider the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate representative cam Kennedy
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
president Bob Linn for the minority of
the committee chair recognizes
representative
Lynn
thank you Mr Speaker colleagues this is
deja vu all over again this bill uh was
originally passed last year by this body
uh but was killed in the other body um I
I will try to keep my remarks relatively
brief basically the issue here as as
I've said last year is does a contract
mean what a contract says that's what
this is all about in 2005 the New
Hampshire Supreme Court issued a
decision in which it said that the fact
that a lease is for a specific term of
for example a year doesn't mean that
it's that it actually is binding on the
tenant um if at the end of the year so
that at the end of the year and by the
way I should say this this applies to
what's called restricted property
restricted property can be as little as
a two family h two you have two rental
unit as long as you don't live in one of
the rental units that's restricted
property and it's covered by this this
decision at the end of the year if the
if if the tenant wants to stay you can't
kick the tenant out evict the tenant
just because the lease is up that's what
the uh what the Supreme Court uh said in
that case it doesn't matter what the
lease says the tenant of course is free
to leave at the end of the year how does
that make any
sense that the decision was uh was not a
unanimous decision of the Supreme Court
and one of the one of the uh justices
who concurred especially was Justice Joe
Netto an appointee of Governor Shaheen a
longtime Democrat and hardly a
right-wing you know extremist here's
what he had to say under the majority's
interpretation lease Provisions
purporting to limit the lease to a
specified Dura uh duration have no
meaning
the effect of the majority's
interpretation is to create a Perpetual
tency virtually a life interest in favor
of a tenant of restricted property
covered by the statute I do not believe
that was the int that this was the
intent of the
legislature the Court's decision was
ostensibly designed to protect tenants
but I ask you to think about this as I
as I said last time and I apologize if
I'm repeating but I think it's important
to say this the the effect of this
decision is this if you are a landlord
and you are considering someone who
might be sort of a marginal tenant
you're not sure this person maybe has a
you know a a a shady credit history um
or some other things some other things
and you now have to decide do I want
this person as my tenant or not if the
law is as it stands now that once you
take that person as a tenant you're
stuck with with with that person or that
family or whatever you're going to think
really really carefully before you make
that decision on the other hand if the
law is as I submit it should be that if
you make a lease for a year it's a lease
for a year so that if you so that if it
doesn't work out at the end of the year
you can say I'm sorry the lease is up
and you know I want you to leave you're
going to be much more likely to be
willing to take that risk if you can
limit it in that
way that's why I believe that we should
defeat this itl motion and support this
will let me say one other thing that I
think it's important to say and that's
concerning my understanding is that at
least some of the reason this bill
failed in the other body was a claim
that well because we have such low
vacancy rates this will this will result
in increased homelessness it's uh you
know we have to we have we can't do this
this whole homeless argument I suggest
to you is a nice a nice sound bite but
if you think it through it doesn't
actually make any sense
it is true that there are very low let's
assume almost No Vacancy rates now it's
down to
like4 or 5% so stop and think about what
that means if if this bill were to pass
and it increased and I think probably
you'd have to say because it gives a
different another reason why somebody
could be evicted it there probably would
be some increase in vacancy rate I don't
think it'd be very much but arguably it
would have some increase but stop and
think about what that means so that
means means somebody gets evicted at the
end of the lease
term so we have a minus one that
person's
out under the current under the current
system under the current uh vacancy
situation isn't it obvious somebody is
going to take that up so we have
somebody back in how does that increase
homelessness is there any reason to
believe that the person who is evicted
is is like any more likely to become
homeless than that the new person that
comes in was homeless and is now no
longer homeless it doesn't make any
sense we all know that the major cause
of the home of the homelessness problem
and the the unavailability of housing is
there's not enough housing how does it
help to encourage people to in landlords
and investors to to uh give us more
housing for rent to make crazy rules
like this that just that just impose you
know really
frankly stupid burdens on the landlord
it doesn't make any sense for that
reason I urge you to uh press the red
button defeat this itl motion so that a
more appropriate motion can be made and
Mr Speaker I would ask for division vote
thank
Kenny uh thank you Mr
Speaker for the last 39 years nearly all
New Hampshire tenants have been
protected by the statutory requirement
that a landlord establish good cause for
eviction regardless of whether they have
a lease this bill would rip a hole in
this vital protection that has served to
balance the interests of landlords and
tenants for nearly four decades I want
to quickly address the idea that this is
a simple
contract one of the first things I
learned in law school in contract law is
that it assumes that the parties have
roughly equal bargaining power this
allows them to negotiate an agement that
considers the needs of both parties I've
been a renter for quite a long time and
to suggest that the power Dynamic is
equal in any way is
incorrect the landlord sets the terms
and the Tenant takes it or leaves it
this is even more true now than
ever with the historically low rental
vacancy of
6% what are tenants likely to do take
what they are offered because they lack
bargaining power because if they say no
it is going to be difficult to find
another option yet a landlord will have
plenty of prospective tenants the
numbers don't
lie it is important to note at the
conclusion of a lease term landlords are
not left without any options they can
still change the lease terms increase
rent decide they no longer want to rent
the property uh decide to rent to a
family member they can move into the
property themselves among other options
the only thing that they cannot do is
swap one tenant for another without
giving any legitimate
reason and conversely the only thing a
tenant can do at the end of a lease term
is decide whether they want to stay and
accept the new lease terms imposed by
the landlord or not and this includes a
rent increase of any
amount this is why yes tenants need
protection and it does make sense this
is why for the past 39 years tenants
have been protected from being
arbitrarily uh evicted because we are
talking about an individual stability
the roof over one of our constituents
heads and logically Mr Speaker any
eviction in this housing market is
likely to result in some period of
homelessness homelessness already grew
55% in New Hampshire between 2022 and
55% and uh that is the highest growth
Nation wide and for the reasons I've
already stated this bill would make an
already dire issue much
worse by increasing homelessness we
would continue to see the disheartening
consequences such as disrupting a
child's education or causing employment
struggles for adults among other
issues to conclude we all know that
there are times when a landlord needs to
evict a tenant and there are many lawful
reasons that allow them to do that that
they just have to have some legitimate
reason because it should not be easy to
take away someone's home good cause
strikes a balance between protecting
property rights of landlords while still
offering some stability for
tenants therefore Mr Speaker I urge my
colleagues to press the green button in
support the bipartisan committee
recommendation of itl thank you Mr
Speaker representative Granger has
requested a roller calls that's
officially
seconded got to be in your seats not
standing there put your hand up you got
seconded Reis representative ly has
requested a division there will be a
division
[Music]
vote
e
motion before us is a majority committee
report of inexpedient to legisl and
House Bill
1115 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Lynn for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know house will be in
order member may continue thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this that the the
uh proposed amendment that I would offer
I mean I'm sorry the proposed bill that
ought to pass if if we defeat this
motion does not eliminate good cause as
a basis for for removal it simply says
that the end of the lease term
constitutes good cause and if I know
that this bill will correct the law to
eliminate the situation whereby a lease
provision specifying its term is
rendered a nullity for the land Lord but
is fully enforceable by the tenant and
if I know that the court decision that
produced this result violates the
contract and property rights of
legitimate business people who provide a
valuable public service by making
housing available to the public and if I
know that the law as it now stands
reduces the availability of housing to
those who are likely to have the most
difficulty in securing housing and
finally if I know that there is no basis
for the claim that this bill will
increase homelessness then would I
oppose the itl motion by pressing the
red button thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognized representative Ming for a
pament
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Mr
Speaker if I know that a contract can be
affected by laws and court rulings not
written into that document and is
therefore governed by more than the
words on the page and if I know that
those those laws and court rulings are
intended to prevent unfair practices
between parties on un unequal footing
then wouldn't I affirm the committee
recommendation of itl by pushing the
green button thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us majority
committee report of inex speeding to
legislate in h Bill 1115 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposed
you press a red button voting stations
seconds
representative
[Music]
please
all members present had a opportunity to
vote 182 voting yay 191 voting nay the
motion
fails to pass representative Lynn moves
ought to
pass are you ready for the question all
[Applause]
I
I have been corrected that there was a
division asked for so we will be a
division
vote all the members still in your seats
I
hope the motion before us is ought to
okay we'll try this again the motion
before us is a to pass on House Bill
1115 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
Bixby all members president had an
uptune to vote Al will attend to stay to
the
vote 194 voting aay 180 voting nay the
passes uh what reason the member rise
thank you Mr Speaker having voting on
the prevailing side I move
reconsideration on HB 1115 and urge the
now are you ready for the
question division has been requested
everybody should be still in your
seats the motion before us is
consideration on House Bill
1115 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
representative
Schmid while members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 175 vote 179 voting a 195 voting a
fail
majority of the committee on Judiciary
to which was referred House Bill 1283 FN
options having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with Amendment Senor
margerie Smith majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate sen w Stapleton
for the minority of the committee for
what reason does a member rise to make a
motion to State your motion given where
we are in the calendar I move to table
hb1
1283 and it is a proper
motion roll call has been requested is
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
sh
[Music]
repr
the motion before us is to table H Bill
1283 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative whole for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that we're only about
halfway through the
calendar if I know that we potentially
are going to be here for a while and
there's a long list of speakers for this
bill if I know this bill adds new
felonies and mandates to the insurance
firms would I now vote to table this
Bill thank you chair recognize
representative marjerie Smith for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker if you know that this
body is described as a deliberative body
if you know that hundreds upon hundreds
of our New Hampshire citizens have come
to participate in the hearings um on
this Bill and have written to us and
called us on this issue if we know if
you know Mr Speaker that the time is
now for us to deliberate a bill that has
attracted all of that interest across
the state and is worthy of that interest
would I now press the red button so that
we could do what this body is expected
to do deliberate thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is table
House Bill 1283 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house will attend to sayate to
vote
155 voting aay 217 voting nay the motion
tbling motion
am we're back to autop pass with
Amendment am right the amendment is
0808 H printed in house record 11 pages
52 to 57 are you ready for the question
on the amendment all
those debate on the amendment not on the
amendment the question is on the
amendment all in favor say I I those
oppose
nay the eyes have it
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is a to pass with
recognize we have uh quite a bit of
debate chair recognizes representative
Christine
Perez thank you Mr speaker thank you
Representatives my name is Christine
Perez I am a state representative a job
that I take very
seriously I make a point to listen to my
constituents and respond to them when
appropriate this is my response to House
Bill
1283 the hearing on House Bill 1283 was
eye openening people are afraid those
both for and against the bill those four
expressed having unbearable experiences
with friends or family or have a fear of
suffering themselves at the end stage of
a terminal disease those against Express
genuine concerns about perhaps being
next the bill causing or the bill
causing increases in other suicides for
example veterans who already have a
disproportionately high rate or as
evidenced by the testimony and an
editorial of a young Stu of young
students who felt that passage passage
might end up making suicide being an
acceptable solution to Life's challenges
for their friends something I had not
thought of but have now taken to heart
would it be acceptable for nursing home
patients to feel they are a burden the
disabled how about children who are
seriously disabled and their parents
want to end their suffering the list can
go on and yes other civilized countries
have dramatically expanded their scope
under the name of
maid right now California has a bill
that dramatically extends their right
their assisted
suicide this bill concerns me it is not
narrowly focused and we are not
Oregon these this H there is no
residence requirement or limitation will
they come from other countries there
aren't even guidelines as required by
hospice other than the six-month window
to death who determines that someone who
has not treated you at all a complete
stranger who reviews your medical record
that is provided by whom who provides
that medical
record there is no no requirement for
your treating
physician the one who has worked with
you throughout your illness to be
involved at all hospice mandates their
involvement honestly to have a gastric
bypass one must have to ensure they are
medically psychologically and
cognitively ready this bill doesn't
require any of that and my life in a
peaceful manner is stated for your
termination of life in this bill yet
this holds no guarantee even Oregon yes
Oregon stated that there are distressing
complications from the ingestions of
these drugs and
14.8% of patients had difficulty
swallowing or experienced regurgitation
seizures or even regained
Consciousness no witness is required
what happens to these lethal drugs if a
patient is decides not to take them or
dies before they use
them there is a page and a half
584 words protecting the health care
provider and the health care
entity if this is such a comprehensive
and thorough Bill why is that necessary
why do they need such extensive
protection a big problem no Reporting
System there is no way to tell how many
actually received the cocktail and how
many used it California states that
Under reporting and abuse of the law is
covered up by the lack of requirement a
requirement that should be there now
there's another red flag to consider
alol the law would state that an
individual's request does not arrive
from coercion there is no penalty for
this but yet if any person knowingly
does anything with the intent to cause
interference with or prevent a person
from following through with ending their
life it is a class B
felony in addition this bill attempts to
dictate what insurance companies are
required to pay for life insurance no
matter what the terms of their policy
are that they agreed to
I could continue with many more
concerns and I want you to know that I
have spoken to two physicians at length
two lawyers and an insurance agent who
share some or all of my points on this
bill I know that you there are many of
you and your constituents that feel
strongly about the intent of this bill
but we're not talking but we're talking
about ending an individual's life we are
certainly owe them a bill that is clear
concise and not open to misinformation
or unintentional or intentional
additions I have been asked to read this
from a constituent this bill sends a
message that we no longer are saying
that we should protect all lives from
suicide it's the message that some lives
are simply not worth it is that the
message we really want to spend send
especially to our youth please press the
red button and let's give the people a
better option A better Bill thank you
does the member yield a questions yes
member
yields member May in
choire thank you Mr
Speaker am I hearing that the doctor has
been treating you has no involvement in
this process and there is no designated
chain of command for the individual's
records to be given to the total
strangers that will be who making the
decision yes that's absolutely true your
doctor who has been treating you has no
involvement in ending your life other
than a medical record not from him
necessarily or her is to be transferred
to the who's making the decision for you
to be allowed there's no chain of
command there's no saying what medical
records you get it could have been from
your primary care and not even your
treating
cono thank you Mr Speaker honorable
colleagues I am going to read an oped
from juules good um I don't think anyone
could say it better juules good is a
disability professional policy
professional activist who lives in New
Market as New Hampshire considers
legalizing assisted suicide also
referred to as Medical Aid in dying I
would like to draw the attention of the
potential impacts this bill could have
on the disabled and other marginalized
residents I was 19 years old the second
time I attempted to die by Suicide I had
just been diagnosed with a chronic but
not life-threatening illness I had
rapidly lost 70% of my hearing in the
middle of completing a music degree and
I was struggling with untreated anorexia
that was taking a serious toll on my
health at my intake appointment with a
new therapist a few days after my
attempt I explained my situation and the
hopelessness I was
feeling she nodded along then looked me
in the eyes and said something I will
never
forget I would probably kill myself if I
were
you she wasn't the first person to say
this to me as I started becoming more
noticeably disabled but she was probably
the last person I expected to do
so now that I work in Disability Policy
nothing surprises me I hear stories from
other disabled people about doctors
pressuring them to sign dnrs because
they are assumed to have a low quality
of life due to their
disability I get messages on social
media from people asking me to how to
advocate for appropriate pain management
when their doctors don't believe the
amount of pain they're
in I pour over story after the story of
people like Michael Hixon in Tinsley
Lewis having treatment withdrawn
withheld or threatened because of the
pervasive view that it's better to be
dead than
disabled this is why I am critical of
policies that are biased toward ending
the lives of people with significant
disabilities rather than towards
preserving them policies like legally
assisted
suicide assisted suicide and the
discussion around terminal illness in
general has historically been framed as
an issue for older adults young people
aren't supposed to have to think about
death yet adulthood for 20s somethings
like me continues to be shaped by a
deadly pandemic mass shootings and
systemic violence we've heard story
after Story of perfectly healthy young
people who got infected with covid and
are now are permanently and
significantly
disabled one of my neighbors a man in
his early 30s was a victim in a shooting
that claimed the life of his 8-year-old
son he sustained permanent physical
disabilities from the gunshot
wound now more than ever young people
need to be invested in Equitable
treatment for disabled people not only
because we are human beings who deserve
care but also because the odds of
younger people becoming disabled or
caring for disabled person are
continually
Rising while proponents claim that
assisted suicide is only for terminally
ill people who are about to die
anyway they ignore the fact that many
disabilities can become terminally ill
if left
untreated in our for-profit health care
System denying or merely delaying care
can make an otherwise manageable
disability
terminal medical racism and transphobia
increases barrier to care resulting in
bipar and trans people reporting
postponing or avoiding Medical Care due
to
discrimination up to a quarter of the
people with chronic illnesses have
chosen not to fulfill a prescription to
manage their condition because of cost
the more vulnerable a person is the more
likely they are to be steered toward
assisted
suicide it doesn't take direct coer to
make this happen a system where death
seems like the best or only option for
the most marginalized patients is not a
system that needs a legal Avenue for
doctors to help us die as my colleague
in prominent disability Justice activist
Anita Cameron has written disabled
people need supports to live not tools
to die a policy of assist to suicide is
not an Avenue for Bly autonomy or Choice
it is yet another tool that can be used
to deny care to those who need it most
thank
you for what reason does a member rise
for a
motion State your motion I move
indefinite
postponement it is a correct motion roll
call has been
requested is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
postponed
oh
your
the house will be in
order the motion before us is indefinite
postponement of house bu
1283 this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative whole for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that those at the end
of life are facing tough
choices and management of pain is
important but ending the life is not if
I know that there are better options for
those that are that are facing the
prospect of dying
or living for a short time with
terminal um medical
issues if I know that this bill
conflicts with other statutes if we pass
it would I now vote Yes and and press
the green button to indefinitely
postpone this Bill thank
you chair recognize representative
margerie Smith for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
just a few minutes ago this body
thoughtfully
realized that they that the body wanted
to act as a deliberative body on an
issue that's important to many people in
this state and if I know that while we
have heard from two of our colleagues
since we had that vote we have not yet
heard from any person who is in support
of the legislation would it not be
appropriate to vote down in definite
postponement so that we could have a
balanced Hearing in order to carry out
our deliberative
responsibility um would I then vote red
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us in dep
postponement for House Bill 1283 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
seconds
[Music]
all members present had opportunity to
vote 150 voting a 20112 voting a the
motion failed chair recognize
representative
MSS
recognized thank you Mr Speaker and good
evening colleag good afternoon not yet
good afternoon colleague
I Rise to speak in opposition to the
motion of ought to pass as
amended I understand and respect that
many people including some of you wish
to have greater control over how their
life ends I applaud the fact that this
has been treated as a nonpartisan issue
I am speaking to you today not as a
Democrat but as a son and as a
father my mother was always very active
and
energetic before immigrating to the
United States she represented the
Netherlands in international
competition she was an avid bowler and
she enjoyed defeating my father in golf
something he very rarely
acknowledged later in her life she
suffered complications from heart
surgery that resulted in both of her
kidneys failing after spending months
going to and spending hours connected to
a dialysis machine she decided that that
really was not for her and she stopped
going to those appointments she passed
away shortly thereafter and my sister
brother and I were never more proud of
her I am also the father of a young man
with what is commonly referred to as
developmental
disability but should be described as an
atypical ability he has the gift of
remembering and recalling an
encyclopedia of facts and I have learned
more about present day and prehistoric
animals than I ever did in
school I also had the privilege of
leading one of the 10 nonprofit agencies
the state uses to support individuals
with similar atypical
abilities through that experience I had
an opportunity to interact with hundreds
of families and most of the leading
organizations and Advocates working to
ensure that the rights of all
individuals with a disability are
protected most of those families and the
following New Hampshire based organ
organizations are opposed to hb1
12383 Abel New Hampshire the disability
rights Center of New Hampshire
strategies for disability Equity the New
Hampshire brain in Injury Association
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
the United spinal Court Association New
Hampshire chapter and the state veterans
advisory committee in addition the
National Council on disability the
nonprofit independent Federal agency
that reports to both the president and
the Congress and most other prominent
National disability organizations are
opposed to op to initiatives like this
why because these laws are inherently
dangerous and harmful to people with
disabilities and other vulnerable
populations while some will claim this
bill is only for terminally ill
terminally ill people who are about to
die anyway in our current health and
social Services System many people with
disabilities can become terminant ill
and if any one of the accompanying
conditions many of them must live with
are left
untreated conditions like diabetes lupus
spinal cord injuries and auto immune
conditions individuals living with a
disability have been and continue to be
at a distinct disadvantage in accessing
appropriate levels of care and support
while we have made good progress in our
country and in our state do not forget
that the federal government has yet to
fully fund the individuals with
disabilities and Education Act and while
this and recent legislatures have made
concerted efforts to raise the level of
fun Medicaid funding to individuals with
disabilities 2 and 3% annual increases
for the past several years does not come
close to F filling the funding Gap
created by many years of neglect placing
the those individuals and their families
at much greater risk than the rest of
the
population some will also claim that the
intent of this bill is to provide
greater bodily autonomy to granted sters
consistent with our Live Free or Die
culture in opposing this bill I would
suggest that before we focus on the word
die in that motto we focus more on the
word live we need to fix the huge
inequities in our health care and social
Services System that vulnerable
populations experience so that they are
able to enjoy the greater autonomy of
their bodies that most of us already
enjoy and so that they can lead the rich
and fulfilling life that they are
entitled to before they
die as a parent of a certain age and
after talking with parents of other
atypical abled
individuals the number one question on
our minds is what will happen to my
child after I'm
gone whether we want to admit it or not
there continues to be a stigmatization
of disability in our society it is one
of the last remaining barriers to
Justice and equality for all that we
still need to address for all that we
need to address with that as our
cultural bias there is a concern that
our loved ones may feel pressured or
coerced intentionally or unintentionally
into ending their lives prematurely with
no one looking out for their best
interests I have concerns about the
safeguards and protections in hb1 1283
to ensure this does not happen to people
with
disabilities the bill requires that
someone who is considering ending their
life must be evaluated by a mental
health
professional but there is nothing in the
bill that mandates that someone with
specific expertise working with
individuals diagnosed with a
developmental dis ability such as autism
must be involved in the assessment of an
individual with that
diagnosis unless you have worked closely
with individuals who are on the autistic
Spectrum you will not know how to
connect with them on a meaningful basis
and how to interpret answers they give
to the questions they are
asked considerable space is spent in the
bill protecting providers who
participate in the end of life process
from
liability additionally space is spent on
the mechanics of what happens next
reporting requirements the effect on the
construction of wills and the impact on
insurance and annuity
policies while some space is spent
protecting individuals who may wish to
end their life from coercion to not move
forward there are not nearly enough
Provisions in the bill protecting
individuals from being coerced or or
coached to voluntarily request or self
administer a terminal prescription for
the purposes of ending their life there
is language in the bill that
specifically prevents the individual's
surrogate decision maker Guardian Health
Care proxy or attorney in fact for
Health Care from initia initiating a
request for medical assistance and
dying that's a pretty extensive list
which probably includes at least one of
the people my wife and I will designate
to help our son after we are gone if
they can't be involved in the decision
then who will help him if someone
suggests to him that he has reached a
point where he should end his life my
experience has been that most
individuals who have been diagnosed with
a developmental disability and received
ongoing supports from others for most of
their lives are very trusting and could
thus be easily manipulated by anyone
claiming to be their
friend how we each vote on this bill
will be a deeply personal decision we
each have to make I have struggled with
it since I first became aware of this
bill while on the one hand I would like
everyone to have the same option my
mother chose to end her
life because of my son and the thousands
of others like him in our state I cannot
vote in favor of it I hope the
perspective I have shared with you will
help you in the decision you will need
to make
thank you Mr Speaker and I would like to
vote representative margerie Smith is
report thank you Mr
Speaker I'd like to begin by saying that
I agree
completely with the words of my
colleague from Hampton he made a very
strong argument for the fact that we as
a society and as a
legislature have not done all that we
could or should do to make sure that we
have guaranteed equal access to health
education housing for people with
disabilities for people of color for
other groups that are not like the
majority he is absolutely
correct where I differ however is that
this bill has nothing to do with that
it's an entirely different subject we
should leave
here committed to do more for others
than we are doing now but has nothing to
do with this
bill in the disperate world that we
occupy we all have two things in common
we are
born and we
die in my earliest years in the
legislature longtime representative
Marian copenhaver along with others
sponsored a bill on this very subject
that came to the Judiciary Committee
that was more than 25 years
ago but the shock that I experienced in
that hearing has stayed with me all this
time caring competent committed
Physicians spoke of how they felt
powerless to help their patients who
were nearing the ends of their the end
of their lives and experiencing
unbearable pain they were concerned that
if they use drugs to minimize the pain
they would be charged with a crime that
same concern was expressed by dedicated
concerned members of the burgeoning
hospice community and by patients
nearing the end of their lives and their
families since then at regular intervals
bills addressing the issues of end of
life have appeared some to form study
committees some to take specific
action for example hospice and pallative
Care have developed significantly in
this quarter Century some passed one
house or another some passed both only
to die on the governor's
desk now we like to be first in the
nation and we certainly know that first
in the nation primaries are incredibly
important to us not many proposals in
this body get a unanimous vote but
sometimes being first in the nation is
goal
what we have to understand is that we
have waited
26 years since Oregon
began
its uh Medical Aid and dying program and
since then they now a total of 10 states
in the district of Colombia we have
watched what went on in those States we
have monitored the results we have seen
where there were problems we very very
carefully decide Ed how to construct a a
conservative bill that learned its
lessons by our not being first in the
nation but by our
waiting this bill is about options it
offers one option to join others that
are available in our laws governing the
end of
life the bill the which is the amendment
which is in the calendar is very long
and if you all are as busy as we are in
judiciary you haven't had a chance to
read the entire Amendment since it
wasn't in your committee I will say also
that the reports in the calendar are
also long because it's a complicated
issue perhaps you've had time to read
those but let me give you a quick
summary
under this bill the request must be
written by the terminally ill person and
it must be signed in front of two
witnesses one of whom at least can't be
related in any
way two Health Care Providers must
evaluate the terminally ill person
independently to confirm that they are
eligible for Medical Aid in dying the
terminally ill person must be capable of
making an informed
decision understanding the full impact
of their
request if either provider has doubts
they must
refer the person to a registered mental
health professional for
evaluation lack of mental capability
stops the process the health care
providers must review all other
treatment and end of life life options
available to the terminally ill person
provide
resources uh to access those options and
confirm that the terminally ill person
is aware they can stop the process at
any
time only the terminally ill person can
request the
medication no one else is authorized to
make this request on behalf of the
terminally ill individual
the terminally ill person must be able
to self administer the
medication must be able to take the
medication on their own by mouth or
other means that are completely
controlled and done by
them a prescription cannot be written
until a dying person completes a written
request and has two
evaluations and two healthc care
providers have confirmed that they are
El eligible that's basically how it
works the bill goes on to talk in uh in
detail about how that works to talked
about the
penalties um that come to anyone who in
any way coerces or in any way provides
inappropriate
pressure I had planned today to focus on
what the bill does but it has become
obvious to me that there is a need to
say what the bill doesn't do and that is
necessary because of the materials that
have been circulated by individuals
concerned with the
bill you might recognize the name
Kenneth Norton he's a licensed
independent clinical social worker who
has spent for decades working to prevent
suicide at the local State national and
international
um uh and he he worked most effectively
here at Hampshire for many years legally
in the 10 states in Washington DC where
Medical Aid and dying is allowed the
death is not counted as a suicide death
medical examiners and coroners list the
underlying terminal illness which the
person was diagnosed with as the cause
of death on the death certificate of
patients who utilize Medical Aid in
dying people who die by Suicide for no
for whatever reason no longer longer
wish to live and feel that they have no
other option than death I'm standing
here and thinking about a very loved
respected former colleague in this
body who felt that the time had come um
and waited one day until his wife went
out shopping and he then went into the
woods and shot himself he did that so so
that his wife wouldn't have been there
to see him do it and would not have the
house become a memory of what he
did um the person who chooses Medical
Aid and dying wants to live doesn't want
to die but wants to
live and has been diagnosed with a
terminal illness that will end their
life and may cause intense suffering
before they die they are fully informed
of other options including pallative
Care Hospice and comfort measures this
is not a decision they are allowed to
take lightly at the spur of the moment
it requires thoughtful controls and two
medical opinions in support of
specific terminal
illness there is a high correlation
between suicide and mental illness the
person who dies by Suicide may or may
not be rational or even competent at
that moment research shows that many
suicide deaths are impulsive although
the person may have complicated
contemplated suicide for some time it
may be only a matter of
minutes between making the decision to
die
and taking their
life thank you by contrast in Medical
Aid and dying people go through a formal
process with the two medical
professionals the assessment
determination of the terminal illness
and informed consent including a review
of available Ops and a mandatory waiting
period people who die by Suicide die
alone and often die by violent means in
the Hampshire over 75% of suicides
involve Firearms or
hanging nationally over 75% of suicide
deaths occur in a home or a primary
residence these violent deaths result in
trauma for their loved ones who return
home to find their loved one
dead the shock and the aftermath are
incredibly distressing and can cause
PTSD First Responders who will call to
the
scene family friends and loved ones of a
person who desire who die by Suicide can
experience intense emotions shock guilt
anger shame um they are devastating to
the family and to the community it is is
said that persons who die by Suicide die
a single death but their family and
friends are left to die a thousand
deaths why am I talking about suicide
I'm talking about suicide because there
are those who are equating Medical Aid
in dying with
suicide a person who goes through the
Medical Aid and dying process frequently
includes love ones in their decision
most die in their home surrounded by
their family and friends the death is
planned peaceful family and friends are
at peace knowing that this was their
choice and their suffering is over this
does not stop those closed persons from
grieving but eliminates the wise and wha
ifs as well as the
trauma there is a difference between
suicide and Medical Aid in dying and it
is important for us to understand
that
another aspect that I want to address
that I had to thought I would have to
has to do with uh the fact that members
of some religious groups have been have
been encouraged to oppose the
bill hearing people say that and I'm old
enough to remember an experience that
I'm going to share with you I went to my
library shelves to pull out the text of
the speech that John Kennedy delivered
to a group of baptist ministers in Texas
in September of
1960 he said I believe in an America
that is officially neither Catholic
Protestant nor Jewish where no public
official either requests or accepts
instruction on public policy from the
Pope the National Council of churches or
any other ecclesiastical Source where no
religious body seeks to impose its will
directly or indirectly upon the general
population
populace or the public acts of its
officials and where religious liberty is
so indivisible that an act against one
church is treated as an act against
all he went on to say I would not look
with favor upon a president working to
sub the first amendment's guarantee of
religious liberty and neither do I look
with favor upon those who would work to
subvert AR article six of the
Constitution by requiring a religious
indirection Kennedy then said I am not
the
Catholic candidate for president I am a
candidate for president who happens also
to be a Catholic I do not speak for my
church on public matters and the church
I share that with you because we are
experiencing all of us um very active
Communications from certain religious
entities trying to say that their
religious beliefs which they hold sacred
and I respect should apply to all of
us then we have heard I want to move on
to another area we have heard from many
of our constituents with disabilities
who object to this bill and why do they
object
they I'm just waiting for it to get a
little quieter they object to not being
eligible to
participate in the many years since
1998 the passage of the organ death With
Dignity act um
um uh has has been in place the dis the
disability rights Center of Oregon has
received very few complaints from
argonians about the act all of the
complaints they have received have focus
on the concern that the ACT might
discriminate against persons with
disabilities who would seek to make use
of the ACT but have disabilities that
prevent them from self- Administration
thereby denying them the ability to use
the act the longtime director of the
disabilities rights ARG and said that
that never to my knowledge have I
received a complaint that a person with
disability was coerced or being coerced
to
participate there is no question that
the disability community and other
groups do not have um equal access to
Health Care education travel
accommodations um I have worked very
hard and will continue to work for equal
access and I know many of you share that
commitment none of this is relevant to
this bill this is a
bill that very few people would take
advantage of remember we'll suspend for
a minute it's getting super noisy in
um I think I've I've I've stressed
enough points but the one point that I
want to remind you of is this is an
option it is a choice it is
possible um for that very few people
will take advantage of it but for those
who do it is a comfort and one last
point I want to make is that for
many of the people who do choose to
participate just having the
prescription is enough they have comfort
from knowing if things get to be too bad
and they can't bear the pain anymore
they have a choice and they can then
keep on trying to live the life that
they want to live remember these are
people people who want to live they
don't want to die what they we could
give them is an opportunity to make sure
that their death is peaceful thank you
very much for your patience does a
member yield for a question
inquire thank you for taking my question
I value your knowledge and the thought
you've put into this highly
I've talked to a lot of people about
this bill some of whom are in the
medical profession and they have
expressed concerns that form the essence
of my question is it possible that this
end of life option could encourage
insurance companies to withdraw support
for people who are facing a terminal
diagnosis whether they choose this
option or not that's a thank you very
much for the question all I can say is
that is a question that helps to
reinforce why we have waited 26 years
before we moved forward on this bill and
that is that there have been no
indications of insurance rates going up
or of there being any pressure from the
insurance industry or anything at all
that changes the status quo once Medical
Aid and dying has been adopted in a
state thank you thank you very much for
the question does a member yield for
another question certainly
representative Hull you may
inquire thank you Mr Speaker real
quickly a little over 50 years ago we
put on our statutes a Prohibition
against assisting in
6304 I don't find in in this um
Amendment or in the bill a repeal of
that is there a repeal of that section
of
law not in this legislation um I think I
have just tried to
explain um perhaps too long so that you
might have lost the point that this is
not suicide it is something that is very
different we are not dealing with people
who want to die we're dealing with
people who want to
live follow up sorry there's a
line no does a member yield for another
question certainly representative
inquire
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker and thank
you my friend from Durham for taking my
question for me the most problematic
atic part of this bill is the 48 hour
waiting period as I understand it in
places that have had this for decades
California and Oregon they have a two-
week waiting period and it seems to me
it might be possible that somebody would
have an immediate medical
crisis and it would take a week or some
number of days to get their medication
rebalanced and and get them back in
feeling reasonable and and in that that
period of Crisis they might want to do
chosen thank you my uh colleague from
Epsom right yes okay those are E Town
sometimes I get confused between Epsom
and eping but um the answer to that was
we wanted to have a reasonable period of
time not just start the process but to
end the
process where it was possible that
someone in Dire Straits could in fact um
get the medication before their life
ended without the comfort of being able
to do it this way remember that no one
is in this
uh is in this program it's horrible word
to use no one is involved in this who is
perhaps just feeling poorly on any given
day these are people who are very near
the end of their life and it it seemed a
reasonable period of time thank you
thank you very much does the member
yield for another one I'm just I'm
looking at the speaker and I think he's
asking me to
stop but thank you very much
and since we share a last name I owe it
you representative Hull is recognized
speak against the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I'll make
this
6304 assisting in suicide
while the prior speaker mentioned that
wasn't this isn't a suicide bill I would
like to read for you the statute
relative to
6304 because I think it does matter that
we talk about assisting somebody else in
life let me just bring it back up I had
it
up
uh 6304 causing or aiding
suicide a person is guilty of causing or
aiding suicide if he purposely AIDS or
solicits another to commit
suicide causing or aiding suicide is a
class B felony if the actor's conduct
causes such suicide or attempted suicide
there is in the bill a notwithstanding
any other law to the contrary but I
challenge the authors of this bill and
Amendment why they didn't specifically
call out this one which is in direct
conflict to the bill as is because
people need to be aware that there is a
class B felony on our books that would
prevent this type of
behavior something that clear should be
in the bill I would ask that you would
oppose the ought to pass
motion and support tabling or itl
because this is not yet ready the
amendment needs more work thank you does
a member yield for a
question sure
one representative cordelli you may
inquire uh thank you Mr speaker thank
you representative um I believe it was
last term we passed legislation that
required student ID cards to have a
suicide hotline number on the back of
their ID cards and you brought up one
RSA about suicide on the books and I
believe there are many more about
suicide prevention um I'm just wondering
um has the Supreme Court ruled on cases
brought in states where there has been a
suicide thank you that's a great
question why I'm not an expert on every
Supreme Court decision I do believe
there is a Supreme Court decision out
there that rules that this is not a
constitutional right for Citizens um and
that the we do have individual rights
but the right to take one's life is not
necessary
um something that the Supreme Court has
ruled positively on thank
you representative Roy recognized speak
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I didn't um I didn't
plan on speaking on this at all actually
I mean I made up how I was going to vote
days ago I I was pretty sure
but I I researched it anyway because I
like to research these things just to
see what's happened and what's going
on thank
you I I didn't originally plan to speak
on this bill um I made up my mind a long
time ago um for private and religious
reasons how I was going to vote on this
bill but I researched it it didn't I
thought affect me personally but in my
research I I was shocked I'm going to
just read something real quick what I
discovered on a on a website called
dying with Dignity it's about Canada's
law what they
did and this is a woman uh who
championed this in Canada and helped get
it past her name was Cheryl she said
I've been alive very long but far from
living since October 2017 due to my
spine and autoimmune issues no chance of
being fixed or even improved grossly
inadequate symptom control and with
knowledge and fear that my condition
will continue decline I was diagnosed as
having adhesive
arachnoiditis one of the most painful
conditions a human being can have it's
up there with metastatic bone cancer and
complex regional pain syndrome the pain
I managed with through progressively
getting worse and we'll continue to do
so I was
denied medical assistance in dying in
2019 so she goes on to talk about how
she helped Canada change it so that it
wasn't just people that were 6 months
away from dying well I'm going to share
with you something pretty personal to me
I have adhesive
arachnoiditis I am an excruciating pain
every day and I could not function
without a handful of medicine that I
take every day to be here sitting in
that chair for hours is excruciating
tonight I probably won't sleep for hours
and it's going to get
worse this bill is the c an's nose under
the proverbial tent because that's how
they started there it was only if you're
about to die and then it was well maybe
if you're in pain and it hurts so much
we're going to help you there too and
that's how it starts and that how it how
it ends I have no contemplation in my
mind of wanting to die when I get up
every day even though it hurts like hell
and I don't want to do it I don't want
to sit here I don't want to sit there I
I just want to lay down and take more
opioids because it hurts so freaking bad
but I come here and I live every day
because I know that I have a duty to my
family my friends and the state if I go
to the doctor and the doctor tells me
hey the insurance company is cutting
back on your
opioids and they're cutting back on your
other pain medications and you gab a pen
and this and that but we will cover
suicide every time they offer that
because now I'm in more and more and
more pain that I can't stand it how long
will it be till they've basically left
me no choice
so when you think that this is something
about a choice a calm person gets to
make and that's not the case and where
you have a a a government running your
Healthcare which people seem to be
asking for a lot you have the doctor and
the insurance companies one person there
there's no difference between the two so
in Canada where they have socialized
medicine your doctor is your insurance
company and you trust that advice I get
care from the VA the doctor is my
insurance company thankfully I have
private insurance as well but I can
imagine shortly if this were the law
federally how long would it be before
they VA said we can't afford this
anymore but for $150 you can have this
shot are we a culture of life or a
culture of death and that's really the
last question I choose to keep living as
long as I can and I choose that for
multiple reasons and despite the
conversation or the statements that were
made earlyer ear about leaving religion
out John F Kennedy made that
speech when he was trying to get elected
because he was being accused of being
controlled by the pope it had nothing to
do with assisted suicide and I guarantee
you if he were here today he would not
be voting for that thank you does a
member yield for a question I do
inquire uh thank you for uh taking my
question uh do you remember in
1981 uh Colorado governor Richard lamb
uh going on the Sunday morning shows and
saying that there was a duty to die and
that the old had an obligation to just
get out of the way do you do you
remember that do you remember what a
huge impact that was on the debate in
80s I do and I'm also old enough to
remember a guy named Dr Cav Oran um all
of you may remember or many of you may
remember and if you don't remember him
you might want to look him up because he
was nicknamed doctor death back in the
80s and he was uh a pioneer of this um
he invented a suicide machine for people
who are sick in Colorado and he he got
sentenced I think I think he died in
prison to be honest with you um but yes
I do
remember representative stapleton's
report
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I rise in opposition
to hb1
1283 medically aided suicide I'm going
to call it what it
is in judiciary we had a whole bunch of
testimony on this bill for several
hours much of it in opposition and the
online
submissions were 128 3 opposed to 651
for it almost 2 to
one but we also got lots of letters
emails phone calls individually from
constituents and concern people
Statewide opposition to the bill
includes many organizations and I'm not
going to name them because they have
been covered before but I'll add a
few the right to New Hampshire right to
life an organization known as not dead
yet um and some of the veterans
organizations that are countering TBI
the traumatic brain injury and
Bishops um probably some other churches
and denominations have also weighed in
the list is
long what all of this points to is the
potential influence state State assisted
or state sanctioned suicide has upon
vulnerable groups when they see
validation for the terminally ill and
feel that their life condition ought to
have that option as
well life becomes cheapened when suicide
becomes
normalized and the natural survival
Instinct to carry
on or get better is diminished as we've
heard it crushes hope for or for
improvement or
recovery vulnerable groups like troubled
youth depressed
disabled the Aged and the infirm
chronically ill and even people
struggling with a poor quality of life
can now be at
risk and all of this puts pressure for
us as legislators to gradually expand
beyond the six-month terminal to any
further maladies that are deemed
suitable and that are asked before
us such has already happened in Canada
when terminal illness was expanded in
2016 to death reasonably
forseeable and in
2023 to serious physical
disability and in March this month was
to be expanded to mental illness
but now being put on hold with
legislation trying to get a three-year
stay on that their concern has finally
Arisen over unanticipated suicide
contagion taking out some 4% of their
population in Oregon suicide rates are
up
41% highest in the
nation as doctors report issuing lethal
prescriptions for conditions Beyond
terminal
illness like for loss of
autonomy reduced capability for
activities or to control bodily
functions loss of dignity and feelings
of being a burden to themselves and
others in 2022 assisted suicide death
surged in California by
63% after SB 380 passed
reducing the wait time from 15 days to
48 hours and forcing doctors to refer
patients request if not providing it
themselves there have been and are
continuing to be litigations in several
assisted suicide States challenging
residency and other restrictions against
expanded
criteria the floodgates have have been
opened and we're not going to be immune
to that Supreme Court Justice Neil
Gorsuch chronicled in his book on
suicide in
euthanasia how legal suicides for
expanded reasons surged to
7.5% of all deaths in the Netherlands
after being legalized there in the
1980s all of it shows a propensity for
expansion
in so many of the proponent letters I
got albeit with heartfelt stories of
family members dying in miserable pain I
was struck by the lack of use trust or
Care having myself been there when
relatives and Friends pasted including
terminal cancel cancer
situations I was confident in the good
care provided
them the lack of trust in the ever
improving hospice and pallative Care
field is
disturbing there are improvements there
yet to be made for
sure but for instance in France they
have the Clay's leonet
law that's c l AE Ys Clay's leonet law
you could look it up in Google and
you'll get the
story where Advanced pallative Care is
provided with skillfully administered
dosages carefully measured to overcome
thresholds of pain but not itself
causing the death instead the body
transpiring
naturally this fulfills valid and
established ethical and moral concerns
in my opposition I represent
constituents and colleagues who respect
the sanctity of life from the moment of
conception to Natural
death one of the parties represented in
this chamber has a platform plank
dedicated to that very
principle those of us who are Faith
Believers trust not only in God but also
in the advances of of medicine that will
find better ways than what this bill
offers and they'll do so with the ethic
Do no
harm please join me in voting no with
the red button so that another and
better itl motion can be made Mr Speaker
I will take no questions and I asked for
a roll call vote thank you Mr speaker
no representative Lind recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise in support of HB 1283 the
bipartisan end of life options act it's
obvious that some members of this
chamber have strongly held views against
this legislation just as some people in
the community do but I submit colleagues
that these are not the views of the
majority of our fellow citizens and I
hope and believe that they are not the
views of the majority of the members of
this house a survey conducted by the
well-respected UNH Survey Center found
that more than 70% of granted Staters
favor this legislation including
majorities of both Republicans and
Democrats a majority of gun owners why
the survey decided to ask that question
I'm not sure but a majority of gun
owners which would include
me 55 uh I'm sorry 53% of Catholics and
importantly 75% of people with
disabilities these numbers are not
surprising because at the most
fundamental level what this bill is
about is
freedom simply put the question each of
you must ask yourself is should a
terminally ill person who is in who is
within six months of death have the
right to make a knowing intelligent and
voluntary choice to end his or her
suffering and peace peacefully die in
their sleep I believe that especially in
this state which so strongly and proudly
proclaims its commitment to indiv
individuality and to Liberty as embodied
in our motto of Live Free or Die the
answer to that question is a resounding
yes I am 74 years old and fortunately I
am in reasonably good health but I know
that I'm in the Autumn of life's journey
and then that in the perhaps not too
distant future I like all of you will
have no choice but to face death when
that 's come that time comes and I am
close to the end with no chance of
survival when hosp hospice and pallative
Care are not enough I think I should
have the option of choosing not to
needlessly suffer and you and all of our
fellow citizens should have the right to
make that same
Choice those of us who support this
legislation understand that many who
oppose it do so for sincerely L held
religious and moral beliefs we respect
your position and would never suggest
that you should be required to accept
Medical Aid and dying for yourselves or
your loved ones we ask only that you
Accord us the same respect and not force
your beliefs on those who choose not to
share them let me take a moment to
dispel some of the myths that have been
circulating in The Ether about this
bill no it does not allow a
dermatologist or podiatrist to prescribe
the end of life
medications both the the prescribing
health care pro provider and the
Consulting health care provider must be
qualified by specialty or experience to
make the diagnosis of a terminal
condition with six months or less to
live no there is no significant evidence
of the endof life medications not
working
um or causing increased pain and
suffering are there occasional
complications yes but these are
exceedingly rare no there is no
statistically demonstrated correlation
between uh Medical Aid and dying
legislation and suicide rates no
insurance companies cannot deny coverage
under Life Health or annuity policies
based on the existence of Medical Aid
and dying or a person's choice to use it
no the bill does not require a witness
to actually see the patient take the
medic medic medic uh the medications
because if we were to do so then to
achieve the presumably unbiased witness
we would have to require that someone
other than a close relative be present
and this would insert an outsider into
what the patient expects to be a last
intimate time with loved ones no the
bill the bill does not prevent a comp uh
competent but disabled person from
Consulting with and seeking advice from
a guardian or s or surrogate before
choosing Medical Aid and dying the bill
merely says that such person cannot be
the ones to make the decision that
decision can be made only by the patient
personally and the bill contains no
residency requirement because that would
very likely be legally valid and even if
it wasn't what proper purpose would be
served by disallowing out of sters from
taking advantage of the peaceful uh
ending afforded by this law I for one am
not worried that New Hampshire will
become known as a state that allows
terminally ill that allows the
terminally ill to die with dignity
finally let me address the so-called
slippery slope argument have you noticed
that much of the attacks on this bill
are not a are aimed not at what the bill
actually says or does but at the fear of
how the law might be changed in the
future some have expressed concern that
this law could be expanded from the
strict and narrowly tailored right to
die for terminally ill patients to
Encompass people with significant but
not terminal disabilities or could even
morph into imposing a duty to die for
such individuals
given the past history of the Eugenics
movement in this country and abroad I Do
Not For a Moment suggest that we should
ignore such concerns it has been nearly
100 years since the 1927 Supreme Court
decision in which Justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes upheld Virginia's mandatory
sterilization law for the mentally
incompetent acerbically declaring that
three generations of imbeciles are
enough fortunately our so our societal
Behavior Uh our societal Behavior over
at least the past 50 years demonstrates
that we have seen the errors of our
attitudes towards the the disabled and
will not repeat them beginning in the
1970s we enacted the Americans with
Disabilities Act the individuals with
disabilities Education Act
and many other federal and state laws to
protect and provide equal treatment to
persons with physical or mental
impairments have we been completely
successful in ensuring the equal
equality for the disabled no but I
believe it is fair to say that our
actions make it very clear that the idea
of dis disrespecting or dispatching
those with disabilities enjoys no
political capital in this day and age at
base the slippery slope argument is
premised on the notion that we as a
legislature or more broadly we as a
society cannot trust ourselves to act
reasonably and responsibly in the future
with respect to Medical Aid and
dying I ask you to to join me in saying
no to that view of the world this bill
is about freedom but like all other
rights Freedom does not mean everyone
should have an unlimited right to do
anything he or she wants to do lines can
indeed must be drawn between what can be
done and what cannot drawing such lines
is precisely the the job of this
legislature it is what we do every day I
believe for example that all of us can
say with confidence that this bill's
requirement of terminal illness within 6
months or less to live as a prerequisite
for Medical Aid in dying constitutes a
full stop and that we will never go down
the road of saying that someone who is
not terminally ill can end his or her
life merely because they are disabled or
depressed and wish to do so no matter
how serious those conditions may be you
will never get my vote for something
like that for these reasons colleagues I
ask you to support the o TP motion by
pushing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker and I respectfully ask for a
division
vote the questions on the majority
committee report have ought to pass as
amended and represent representative
Stapleton has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
all
right
e
C
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass is amended on
House Bill
1283 representative muns is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that hb12
83 deals with an extremely difficult and
personal issue and that the rights of
everyone needs to be respected including
not only those who are close to death
but also our most vulnerable population
equally and if I know that most
individuals with disabilities and their
families are opposed to H B
1283 and most of the new New Hampshire
based organizations advocating for the
rights of our most vulnerable population
are also opposed to HB
1283 and if I know that I am not
concerned about what the bill might do
in the future but what it could very
well do
today and if I know that we need to fix
the huge inequities in our health care
and Social Services System that
vulnerable populations experience so
that they are able to enjoy the full
autonomy of their bodies that most of us
already enjoy and so that they can lead
the rich and fulfilling life that they
are entitled to before they die and
finally if I know that hb1
1283 does not adequately answer the
question what will happen to my child
when I am gone that so many parents are
asking themselves right now would I now
press the red button on the motion of
1283 representative Phillips is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker hello again
if I know this bill is rooted in
compassion offering those nearing the
end of their lives the dignity to end
their suffering if they so choose if I
know this bill embodies
Freedom recognizing each individual's
right to make decisions about their own
death in alignment with their values
conscience and Faith free from external
influence moreover if I know it reflects
Reason by drawing on a foundation of
evidence and safeguards with seven out
of 10 Granite Staters expressing a
desire for this Choice it's clear that
this option is both wanted and warranted
finally Mr Speaker if I stand for
Liberty granting terminally ill
individuals in our state the option to
peacefully pass away in the comfort of
their home surrounded by their loved
ones would I press the green
button the questions on the majority
committee report of oop pass is amended
on House Bill 1283 and this is a roll
call vote if you are in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 179 in the affirmative 176 in the
adopted
the committee on Judiciary to which is
referred House Bill 1353 ative
authorizing the commissioner Department
of Education to issue subpoenas comes
without recommendation sen cutab moves
ought to pass and offers Amendment
0978 printed in house record 11 pages
57-
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I those oppose
[Applause]
room
this is a this is a division vote on
0978 if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
now
repres all members present opportunity
vote 169 voting a 178 voting a the
amendment fails we're on to autop pass
chair recognizes representative majer
Smith for what reason doesn't member
rise move to
table Motion in order motion is in order
the motion is to table House Bill
1353 everybody should still be in their
requested
e
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1353 this is is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
represent
Herbert
all members present an opportunity vote
how attend to stay the
vote 292 voting aay 58 voting aay 1353
rise
majority the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 1664 FN an
act relative to Legal remedies for
individuals who receive medical dist
transitioning and considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate sentive Eric Tura for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the say being unable to agree
with the majority Report with the
following Amendment the recommendation
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
present Christine Perez from the
minority of the committee for what
reason does a member rise I would like
to move in definite postponement on
House Bill
vote
representative H has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote the motion
clear
the motion before us is indefinite
postponement on House Bill 1664 this is
a roll call vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill doesn't
prohibit anything
but extends new
options to minors and young adults who
may choose to
detransition if I further know that
there was a recent release of a number
of emails and files from the World
Health sorry the world professional
association for transgender Health
calling into question some of these
treatments if I further know that
long-term benefits from these treatments
are now in
question and lastly Mr Speaker if I know
that California just looked and the
suicide rate is increasing for those who
have taken trans have gone the path of
transition surgery not
decreasing what I now vote read on the
indefinite postponement so the
underlying bill can be discussed thank
you chair recogniz R samura for
parliamentary
Speaker if I know know that this bill
attempts to misuse and distort our
state's medical malpractice laws to
restrict access to gender affirming care
in ways that are completely unrelated to
any errors in medical care or prior um
consent and if I know that it introduces
a range of uh Provisions into medical
tort law that violate long-standing
precedence in terms of establishing inj
any injury
or any malpractice on the part of the
provider and expands the
the uh statute of
limitations in in ways that are
completely unprecedented and finally if
I know that it eliminates the burden of
proof normally
required to um bring and succeed in a
medical um injury claim would I press
the uh um green button in order to
indefinitely postpone this Bill thank
you the motion before is to IND
definitely postpone 1664 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
for
while members present had an opportunity
to vote how will attend to say the
vote 181 voting yay 164 voting nay 1664
Poston majority of the committee on
labor on the real EST of services to
which was referred House Bill
1246 an act relative to allowing for
silver having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolve that it's inexpedient to
legislate sen Brian Sullivan from the
majority of the
committee
minority minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment repr Michael Granger
committee chair recognizes
representative
Granger thank you Mr speaker folks I'd
like to tell you a short story some of
you may have already heard it but about
4,000 years ago Abraham's wife Sarah
died he needed to bury her so he
purchased a field for 400
shekels 400 shekels is 145 Troy o of
silver one troy ounce of silver is worth
$25 so that means the value of the field
$3,625 using the power of the internet I
have found land in Jordan that can be
purchased for less than that
amount 400 shekels can still buy a plot
of land 4,000 years later now compare
that to the dollar which has lost over
90% of its value in less than 100 years
this isn't a new phenomenon empires have
been debasing their currencies
practically since there have been
Empires the US is not immune to the laws
of Economics nor are they immune to the
wages of time maybe the US will last
another Thousand Years perhaps 2,000
years the dollar however almost
certainly will not last as long as the
world Reserve currency at the current
rate it is somewhat doubtful that it
will even last another 10 years as the
world Reserve currency in fact the
Talking Heads have a new euphemism for
it they call it dollarization you might
have heard that term uh because it hits
a lot softer than currency collapse it's
showing up right about on time too as
historically Reserve currencies lose
dominance after about 80 to 100 years
the dollar may very well join the Dutch
Gilder the Spanish reel and the pound
sterling as a former Reserve
currency but when that happens people
will still want to buy groceries I know
I will therefore this is simply enabling
legislation that legalizes wages to be
paid in gold and silver it does not
mandate that wages be paid in gold and
silver it does not force employees to be
PID to pay out in gold and or to be paid
in gold and silver it does not force
employers to pay in gold and silver if
you do not want to be paid in gold and
silver don't get paid if you don't want
to pay in gold and silver don't pay
people merely enabling legislation
between two people who agree it has no
impact on anyone in any way unless that
person wants to be paid in gold and
silver so I'd ask you to please oppose
the itl motion uh thank you Mr Speaker
Sullivan thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker HB 1246 would allow an
employer to pay employees in gold or
silver I rise in support of the itl
motion for this bill legal tender in the
United States is the US dollar gold and
silver are Commodities that change in
value several times each day I would
suggest that if you like gold and silver
invest in gold and silver take your hard
earned money your dollars and buy gold
and silver it might be a good investment
and all the more power too if you decide
to do
that it's impossible for an employer to
know how much gold or silver valued in
dollars an employer would provide to an
employee to meet
payroll the New Hampshire Department of
Labor and the US Department of Labor
have no Provisions for applying wage and
labor laws for this form of
compensation if payroll was somehow a
accomplished an employee would be left
with a ration of gold or silver unable
to buy groceries until the precious
metal was converted to doll dollars that
conversion would involve paying a fee so
the employee would lose a portion of
their pay in order to spend it I also
wonder where one would go to make that
conversion this bill is unnecessary
impractical and largely impossible to
implement please join me in voting green
to support the committee recommending
recommendation of inexpedient to to
legislate and I guess I'll go along with
you representative Granger has requested
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the motion before us is majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator and House Bill 1246 this is a
roll call vote chair recognizes
representative beler for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this is simply
enabling legislation that does not
require either party but requires both
parties to
agree if I know that the government
tends to move too slow in a crisis
situation to legislate on the spot if I
know that this creates a legal path that
in a crisis such as hyperinflation or
the introduction of a new currency or
Central Bank digital currency and
further if if I know that it's better to
have it and not need it than the needed
and not have it would I then press the
red button to overturn this motion that
another might be
made chair recognizes Brian Sullivan for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that legal tender in
the United States is the US dollar and
if I further know that paying wages in
gold and silver is unnecessary
impractical and impossible to implement
would I now press the green button to
support the itl motion thank you the
motion before us majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislator
House Bill 1246 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
[Music]
represent
r
all members present had opportunity to
vote El will attend to state to the
vote under2 voting aay 155 voting a the
committee report is
adopted
committee on labor Industrial
rehabilitative Services to which is
referred House Bill 1648 act relative to
electronic payments to employees debit
cards considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate Senor Brian Sullivan for the
committee are you ready for the
question
for Mr Speaker I move to indefinitely
16848 motion is in
seats
the motion before us is to indefinitely
postpone House Bill
1648 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
e
[Music]
represent
Downes
all members present had the opportunity
vote
postponed
committee on legislative Administration
to which was referred House Bill 1479 FN
relative to prohibiting the use of
federal state or local funds for
lobbying activities this comes without
recommendation representative Hill moves
ought to pass
and offers floor Amendment
0982 H printed in house record 11 page
Hill
yeah thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr Speaker
the amendment offers uh before you
offers two things one it requires a
handful of L firms who offer a wide
range of services to create and price
their programs in such a way that the
municipality can opt out of lobbying if
they choose to the goal here is to allow
those who want lobbying services to keep
them and those who don't want lobbying
Services would not be required to have
them if you like your lobbyist you can
keep your
lobbyist the decisions would be made at
the local level this is true local
control the other provision of the
amendment requires lobbyists to do what
should have been their responsibility
since
2003 when the law was first passed RSA
155 requires anyone who receives State
Appropriations and grants to segregate
the state funds in a completely
different account so no State funds are
to be used to purchase lobbying Services
the amendment also so requires lobbyists
to Pro uh to prove that they inform the
client about this
RSA those are the only two things this
amendment
Amendment the motion before us is the
0982 are you ready for a question on the
amendment all those in favor division
has been requested members take your
seats
e
the motion before us is Amendment
0982 H this is a division
vote it's on the amendment if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppose you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 135 voting a 207 voting a the
amendment failed
bills
on bills on second reading open to
further Amendment pres of Ella office
floor Amendment
question chair recognize representative
Amendment thank you Mr
speaker today I urge the body to focus
on C this uh crucial measures of this
amendment that Safeguard the taxpayers
interests promote transparency ensure
fairness and enhance Civic engagement
firstly uh let's ensure taxpayer funds
are used widely wisely to seek and by
seeking voter permission for this
advocacy this simple step aligns
spending with the Citizen's values and
priorities trans parcy is key every
dollar on lobbying should be spent
subject to public scrutiny and approval
this is about accountability and earning
the trust of the people we
serve fairness matters getting voter
consent before using taxpayer money
ensures everyone has an equal say in how
public resources are
allocated engagement is
essential empowering citizens to
directly influence how their tax dollars
are spent Fosters a a stronger democracy
we must also ensure clients and
municipalities are aware of restrictions
using uh State funds for lobbying since
the laws on the books are not being
followed and prevent coercion by Banning
bundled services like training uh that
most want with lobbying Services which
at least some do not let's PRI
prioritize these measures in upholding
democracy accountability and Trust of
our constituents and adopt this
you the motion before us o Kell Flor
Amendment
116 are you ready for the
question division has been requested
seats
for
the motion before us is yella floor
Amendment
1160 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you press the red
seconds
[Music]
for
represent
man all members present have an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
state of the
vote 117 voting a 224 voting a the
amendment
fails for what reason
remember for a motion
we nov member rise uh for a motion State
your motion table motion to table House
Bill
1479 roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
be
it
okay representative yell had requested a
seconded this will be a roll call vote
on the tabling motion of
is
the motion before us is a table House
Bill 1479 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote house attend to stay to the
vote
fails for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I Rise to make a motion State
your motion I move to indefinitely
order I believe that is a second on the
request this will be a roll call vote
seats
a motion before us is definitely
postpone House Bill 1479 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30
seconds
e
repres
re all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay to the
vote 21 voting a 129 voting
postponed majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to with
referred House Bill
1053 an act relative to permissible
resident units in a commercial Zone and
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate represent
Jim magori for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative joshu will call for
the minority of the committee for what
reason does it member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion motion to table House Bill 104
53 motion is in order the motion is to
1053 are you ready for the question a
requested
anything
the motion before us is to table House
Bill
1053 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your oppos you press the red button
seconds
[Music]
repres
all members president have an
opportunity to vote house attendance
vote 316 voting a 18 voting a house bill
table defin
postp majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill
111 act establishing a committee to
study a potential State program to make
loans to load to moderate income
households for the purpose of buying a
home or for the purpose of consolidating
student loans having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate was of Tim kahill for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being enable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass pres Julie Gilman for the minority
of the committee for what reason does it
member rise motion of indefinite
postpone on HB 1101 Mr
Speaker that is a proper motion the
motion is to indefinitely postpone House
Bill
111 division ised a division has been
requested members take your
seats
she
the motion before us is indefinite
postponement on House Bill
111 this is a division vote chair
recognize representative Reed for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that by every metric New
Hampshire is undergoing not only the
worst housing crisis that we've ever
experienced as a state but indeed our
increase in homelessness is higher than
any other state by increasing 52% a year
and if I know that this bill is simply
studying the feasibility of possibly
creating a program that would eventually
be at no cost to the state doing what
banks already do for profit and if I
know that we need to deal with the
housing crisis or we will not have
workers in this state in 15 years would
I now vote red so that we can actually
talk about fixing the biggest crisis in
this
state chair recognized representative
turot for parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker if I know multiple
programs already exist in both the
public and private sector that addresses
the concerns of this bill and if I also
know that we have seen the catastrophic
results when politicians and bureaucrats
insert themselves into these types of
issues an example being the 20072 2008
financial crisis and finally Mr Speaker
if I know that yet another study
committee is not needed would I press
the green button to indefinitely
postpone HB
1101 the motion before us is to
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
represent
Dolan
if all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
state to the
vote 171 voting yay 164 voting nay House
postponed
committee on Municipal and County
government to which was referred house
bill7 fign relative to the official
ballot referendum form of town
meeting this comes without
recommendation representative power
moves ought to pass the chair recogniz
magori thank you Mr Speaker colleagues
this bill would change the process for a
town to adopt the official ballot
referendum sb2 form of government
reversing an important change in law uh
reversing an important change to the law
that passed in
2019 the basis to oppose this bill is
that voters should vote on a fundamental
change to their town meeting structure
in the same manner they currently vote
on nearly everything else the floor of
the town meeting that way voters also
have a chance to debate and discuss the
question putting it on the ballot takes
that critical voice away from the voter
proponents of the town meeting emphasize
that it is the purest form of democracy
it ensures that all policy decisions are
in the public interest since no
intermediaries are placed between the
voter and the public decisions this
format allows for any and all citizens
to directly debate and vote on
legislation the process under the
current law which requires the question
of whether to adopt s SP2 to be voted on
at the business section SE session not
the ballot makes perfect sense the
question of whether to fundamentally
change your town government should be
voted on voted in using the town's
current process under this bill we would
return to the illogical pre-2019 process
where the voters in a traditional town
meeting would vote on this important
question the light went out I killed the
light there it is uh would vote on this
important question on the official
ballot instead having only one public
hearing which we know are poorly
attended this bill would also strip
voters of their opportunity to discuss
and debate and really understand the sb2
proposal before voting the question that
would go on the ballot is prescribed by
Statute and it merely says shall we
adopt the provisions of RSA 40 colon 313
known as SP2 to allow official Town
ballot voting on all issues before the
town on the second Tuesday of March or
may or April that's it only the most
diligent and informed voters have any
idea what it means before they're voting
what is the deliberative
session what is the default budget how
is the default budget calculated can the
voters amend the default budget and many
more questions what the current law does
do is ensure that the questions get more
careful consideration using a familiar
format in 2019 the house Municipal and
County government committee voted to
recommend the bill to affect this change
by an 18 to1 vote the vote in the house
was on a Division vote it was 235 to
122 it passed the senate committee
unanimously and passed the Senate on a
Voice vote for these reason I ask you to
oppose the autop pass motion so that
another motion can be made thank
you chair recognize repite of
power
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in support
of the ought to pass motion on House
Bill
1175 this bill restores the original
method of adopting the official ballot
referendum form of meeting commonly
referred to as SP2 Mr Speaker for nearly
25 years the question to adopt SP2 was
placed on the official ballot and voters
were able to vote on SP2 adoption at the
polls on Town election day this process
was wisely designed by legislators in
1995 to avoid disenfranchising voters
who could not attend the annual meeting
voting for SP2 adoption on the official
ballot was working very well for 24
years I know this to be true because up
until the change was made a total of 151
towns and school districts successfully
adopted the SP2 form of meeting then in
2019 for no good reason there was a
change in the law that made the adoption
question a warrant article at the annual
meeting requiring voters to attend the
meeting to be able to vote on the on the
question to adopt s SP2 consequently if
a voter for whatever reason is unable to
attend the annual meeting they are now
denied the ability to vote for this very
important change interestingly since the
law was changed only one jurisdiction
has adopted sb2 you heard me right just
one out of 38 adoption
attempts clearly since 2019 law change
adoption of sb2 has essentially been
held hostage ironically the current
method of adopting SP2 at the annual
meeting disenfranchises the same voters
SP2 is intended to help which is why
this bill is important disenfranchised
voters include elderly disabled
individuals people with health concerns
couples with young children
business Travelers college students
snowbirds night and weekend shift
employees military members and more all
of these voters are disenfranchised as a
result of the law change and most of
these disenfranchise voters are
interested in SP2 because it enables
their voices to be heard at The Ballot
Box it's ironic that these citizens
cannot attend the traditional meeting to
vote to adopt SP2 which is exactly the
meeting system that would eliminate
their
disenfranchisement and lastly Mr Speaker
it is important to note that the data
consistently shows that many more voters
cast ballots on Election Day than are
able to
participate at an annual meeting when
more people are able to vote and have
their voices heard this provides better
representation of the will of of the
people in a town or a school district in
making the decision as to whether or not
to to adopt SP2 for these reasons I urge
my fellow colleagues to support the UT
to pass motion by voting yes on House
Bill
1175 and I ask for a division vote thank
you Mr
Speaker pres power has asked for a
division vote this will be a division
vote members take your
seats
for
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 11 75 this is a division vote
chair recogniz the representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know discussion and debate are
fundamental to our democracy and if I
know that discussion and debate on the
issue of transitioning from traditional
form of town government to sb2 is vital
for residents to understand the
implications of their vote would I now
voice my support of the OTP motion by
pressing the excuse me may I
Voice May I then press the red button to
oppose the OTP motion so that a
different motion can be made thank you
Mr Speaker chair recognize rip Center
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that for nearly 25 years the
question to adopt s SP2 was an official
ballot question to ensure that voters
were not
disenfranchised and if I know that for
no good reason the question to adopt s
SP2 was changed to a vote at the annual
meeting a change that without a doubt
has disenfranchised many classes of
Voters and has in effect stopped SP2
from being adopted and if I further know
that this bill fixes the problem by
placing the question to adopt SP2 back
onto the official ballot ensuring that
no voter is
disenfranchised would I know now vote
Yes to support the motion of ought to
pass and push the green button so that
every voter will have a voice in their
town or School District thank you Mr
Speaker the motion will be for us is
ought to pass on House Bill 1175 this is
a division vote you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're oppos you
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
e
all members if all members present had
an opportunity to vote also will attend
vote 173 voting aay 163 voting a
adopted committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
house bill 1210 relative to the election
of straford County Commissioners this
recommendation for what reason does a
member rise a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion motion to indefinitely
postpone hb1
1210 motion is a correct motion the
motion before us is an inde defly
1210 I have a
motion State your
motion I move to lay House Bill 1210 on
the
table as is a correct motion so now we
are have a motion before us to table 12
1210 division vote has been requested
members take your
seats roll
speaker
representative turot I ask for a roll
call that is efficiently seconded this
vote
the motion before us is the table housee
bill 1210 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative grassy for a
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if if I
know that since
1856 Commissioners in straford County
have been elected at large and that over
the last four years straford county has
six elections that had no Republicans on
the ballot and another 15 times that
Republicans did not fill all the
positions on the ballot and if I know
over the same period we would have 16
different County Commissioners six of
those have been good Republican
Commissioners if I know further that for
many of those years Republicans held
countywide positions of County sheriff
and County
Treasurer and fact I know that in the
last 10 elections towns have had elected
representation in nine of those
elections and I know if you run good
candidates you win elections what I now
push the red button so that another
motion may be
made
turot thank you Mr
Speaker if I know it was just last year
that after many decades straford County
joined the other nine New Hampshire
counties to have their Commissioners
elected by district and not at
large and if I know there is nothing
more that the three current
Commissioners would love to go back and
continue the days when there was no need
to campaign
due to an atlarge countywide District
that was gerrymandered by
default and if I know the legislation
passed last year to D District district
straford county for the first time will
give the Republicans who live in
straford County who make up 49 42% of
the electorate uh
voice they will have the potential for a
seat at a the commissioner's table for
the very first time time would I now
press the red button so another more
appropriate motion can be made thank you
Mr
Speaker the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1210 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
Bo
all members president have opportunity
vote 167 voting aay 170 voting nay
postpone are you ready for the
question the division has
speak sen jerard ask for roll call that
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
vote
e
the motion to is inde definitely
postpone House Bill
1210 chair recogniz representative
stavis for a parliamentary
inquiry should go first represent
stavis it's getting late chair
recognized representative Len terot for
a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know the
motion before you is now the appropriate
motion I mentioned in the last
Pi would I now press the green button to
find this bill indefinitely postponed
thank you Mr
Speaker Jer andiz representative stop is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that redistrict can only take
place once every 10 years and that last
year straford County was redistricted
outside of that cycle and if I know know
the purpose of that cycle is to align
with the census and avoid constant
attempts to change districts in favor of
one party or another would I now press
the red button to vote against the
indefinitely postponed motion thank you
Mr
Speaker motion before us is indefinitely
postponed House Bill 1210 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
representative
Canon all members president had an
opportunity need to vote house will
vote 168 voting yay 169 voting nay the
motion
pass now we representa stavis moves are
to
pass chair
recognizes
turot thank you Mr
Speaker hb1 1210 is nothing more than a
partisan attempt to overturn the
legislation that we passed uh signed n
was passed and signed into law last year
straford County was the only one of 10
counties in our our entire state that
elected their Commissioners at large
rather than by
District in a county that is 58 42
Democrat to
Republican one can see why all the
current Democrat straford County
Commissioners and the delegation members
want to
see the law
reversed in the last 40 years only two
Republicans were elected as
Commissioners out of a possible 60
electoral plots hardly representative of
the 42% of us Republicans who live in
the
county reversing last year's legislation
which created districts for the first
time districts not
redistricting we returned straford
County to the geremander by default
County that it has been thus continuing
the voter disenfranchisement of the last
four
decades if we went back
to a county where the Commissioners were
elected at
large you would have in fact a jander
county and what's jander what does that
mean to intentionally create politic
dist political districts that greatly
favor one party over the other and
that's exactly what has been going on in
straford County for the last 40
years now we've heard the
commissioner mcair of our County
mentioned multiple
times that this is unconstitutional in
fact it is not
unconstitutional uh Before the bill was
went forward we contacted the Secretary
of State he said it was absolutely
acceptable and when Senator gray
requested an interpretation from their
attorneys he ALS they also said it was
acceptable the other thing that we've
heard over and over is it's been working
fine as it is
well yeah of course it has been working
fine as it is when you have three
Democrat individuals controlling the
entire County without any uh
counterbalance or checks and balances of
course it works fine for
them but with a 2414 delegation uh
Democrat majority everything proceeds
very smoothly for
them the other thing commissioner mlar
loves to say is we have had Republicans
that we have worked with well yes but
those have been sheriffs and registar of
deeds and others in the county and as I
said before only two Commissioners in
the last 40 years have been elected as
County the association of counties came
forth and
recommended this in favor yet not one of
the other Commissioners actually showed
up to testify no written support no
voice
support and I think it it's fair to say
propose legislation that mandated every
County be elected at large I bet you
you'd have some uh Commissioners in here
belly aing about that so uh I would ask
that you uh vote red on the OTP motion
so a motion of itl can be made thank you
Mr Speaker you recognize representative
stavas
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker without passage of
hb1 1210 limiting redistricted to once
every 10 years no second bites at the
Apple we could see districts
flip-flopping every term depending on
which party has the
majority but this bill gives us a chance
to avoid that kind of chaos and affirm
that we expect people to follow the law
and play by the rules and with respect
to redistricting it's every 10
years it's been clear from the outset
that the majority of straford County
voters did not want their District
divided when hp75 was first presented to
our committee we asked why it hadn't
been dealt with at the appropriate time
and the answer was that it would have
and I quote muddied the waters and
somehow the there wasn't
time but those Waters were pretty clear
since no one showed up at the
redistricting hearings meant to gather
public input as for there not being time
why were was there time to make changes
elsewhere but not in straford
County Mr Speaker all we have to fall
back on here are rules and laws hb1 1210
does nothing more than insist we follow
the rules we ourselves have
endorsed if we don't we'll be fighting
this battle every term every session and
probably in every
County Mr Speaker I urge my colleagues
to vote out to pass on hb12 10 let's
stop playing political political games
by following the rules only when they're
in our favor that's not what we were
sent here to do thank you Mr
Speaker a division has been requested
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote pres Sweeny has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
vote
e
let
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 1210 this is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
turot for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know just last year this
after many decades straford County
joined the other nine New Hampshire
counties to have their Commissioners
elected by district and not at large and
if I know the legislation passed last
year to district straford county for the
first time will give straford county
Republicans who make up 42% of the
county an
electorate of the electorate a voice and
seat at the commissioner's table for the
very first time time would I now press
the red button so another more
appropriate motion can be made thank you
Mr Speaker chair recogniz representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker you can call it
districting all you want but it is
really
redistricting if I know that
redistricting can only take place every
10 years and that last year straford
County was redistricted outside of that
cycle and if I know that the purpose of
that cycle is to align with the census
and avoid constant attempts to change
districts in favor of one party or
another if I further know that the
majority of straford County residents
did not seek and do not want the
district's last year's bill created what
I now press the green button to pass hb1
1210 restore equilibrium to the county
and ensure that everyone here follows
the laws we all swore to obey when we
took office thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1210 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're oppos
press a red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent Papa
Mller
all members present and an opportunity
vote 16 8 to 168 the speaker did vote to
fails what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move to lay House Bill
1210 on the table and I request a
pi the motion is to the motion is to lay
House Bill 1210 on the
table and she's asked for a division
vote everybody still should be in their
the
yes the motion before us is inexpedient
to
legislate I think Steve is going to be
taken over for a few few votes the
motion before us is the table House Bill
1210 this is a division
vote chair recognizes representative
Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that a tabling motion has
failed if I know that an indefinite
postponement motion has failed if I know
that an ought to pass motion has failed
if I know that we need a dispositive
motion on this bill before we can go on
to finish our
business would I now vote because the
tabling motion can be renewed would I
now vote to press the green button for
tabling so I implore you to let us get
on with our business thank
you the motion before us is to table
House Bill
1210 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press a if you're in
favor you'll press a green button if
you're opposed you'll press a red button
seconds
[Music]
repres
it members need to be in their
seats Representatives we're still in a
voting
mode
that I need a thumb up or down please
thank
you
set
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
one 308 voting yay 28 voting
yeah I'm going to have I'm going to
speech you can do the pi want to do the
pi to do the pi on the table mode oh
sure you yeah yes yeah
dokie the of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
referred House Bill 1281 an act relative
to zoning restrictions on residential
rental property having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Jim majori for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Diane power
for the minority of the committee for
what reason does the member
rise for a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion motion to table hb1
1281 representative Len turkot moves at
House Bill 1281 Bel laid on the table
question all right it'll be a division
seats
e
the house will come to
order just so you
know that's the last time I'm going to
wait that long for everybody to get
in and I don't care how the vote turns
out I don't care what the mix is or
who's out there
but the question is whether to lay House
table representative stavis recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that hp12 81 is a
well-intentioned bill that might well
add additional housing stock to our
state which we sorely need but that
there are several technical
flaws mly having to regarding Life
Safety codes that need to be addressed
and if I further know that much more
work needs to be done on this bill
before it can be considered an in a much
more full way would I now press the
green button to support the tabling
Speaker the question is where the Lous
reason there's no hope for
me so the question is whether little a
house bill 1281 on the table and for
some inexplicable reason it's a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
for
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attenda the state of
the vote thank God we recorded this
one 300 and support 17 opposed it's laid
table
the majority on Municipal and County
government to which was referred House
Bill 1317 FN local an act relative to
Municipal filings made by charitable
organizations exempt from taxation
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass representative Laurel stavis for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
in expedient to legislate representative
John McDonald from the minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker go on
ahead I move to lay HB 1317 on the table
vote representative stavis moves at the
house bill 13117 be laid on the table
and this will be a division vote members
take your seats I I'll wait like 90
vote
e
order the motion is whether to lay house
bill 13117 on the table representative
Davis is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that a technical issue surf
surfaced very late in the process with
this bill that could affect is basic and
underlying intent and if I know that the
flaw can't be fixed this late in the
process would I now press the green
button to support the tabling motion and
let us return to the bill at a later
date thank you Mr Speaker the questions
whether to lay house bill 13117 on the
table this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button opposed
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
representative
months
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend on the state of the
vote the vote of 306 to7 house bill
table the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred as Bill 1345 an act
relative to the length of terms for Coos
County officers having considered the
same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Julie Gilman for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Len turkot from the minority of the
committee representative yell is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker I rise today to address a matter
of great importance to the Democratic
Integrity of our
state the recent decision to extend the
terms of Rockingham County officers from
two to four years on the under the guise
of reducing campaign burdens was a
misstep that threatens the very
Foundation of accountable
government now we stand at a precipice
of further entrenching this error by
extending the same extended terms to
Coos County officers while the idea of
campaigning less may seem appealing on
the
surface we must remember that the core
principle is at stake here
accountability to the people we serve
elections are not just inconveniences to
be avoided they are the lifeblood of our
democracy the means by which the
electorate holds us their elected
representatives accountable for our
actions and decisions by extending the
term of office we risk perpetuating and
entrenching uh entrenchment of
incumbents in power which could
concentrate power in the hands of a few
individuals or political parties longer
terms provide a breeding ground for
complacency and a barrier to entry for
new voices and pre fresh
perspectives this undermines the very
essence of our democracy while
competition and diversity of ideas
should flourish shorter terms allow for
greater flexibility and responsibility
to emergent issues and adapting to
changing circumstances they ensure that
our government remains agile and
responsive to the needs and aspirations
of the people rather than stagnating
under the weight of
inertia would you vote for a governor to
be elected every four years because the
job is complicated and takes time to
learn
I know I wouldn't in conclusion while
the temptation to reduce the frequency
of Elections may be understandable we
must not lose sight of the fundamental
importance of the accountability and
responsivness in our de democratic
system we must resist the all the Allure
of prolonged uh terms and instead
reaffirm the commitment to the
principles of democracy transparency and
accountability I urge my esteemed
colleagues to reconsider the path we are
about to take and uphold the sanctity of
our electoral process thank you Mr
Speaker representative Gilman's
report thank you Mr Speaker each county
is managed by a three- member Board of
Commissioners that are typically elected
for two-year terms and they work the
overall supervision of the county
part-time their jobs are
part-time uh but Sullivan County beln
County Marat Carol Hillsboro and Coos
elect one commissioner to a four-year
term and they all work part-time the
positions of County attorney Sheriff
Treasurer register deeds and registered
probate are currently elected to
two-year terms each of these positions
work
full-time all
year these positions operate
administratively like our state
departments which have appointed leaders
and no term
limits continuity through the length of
time of leadership experience is key to
managing the efficiency of personnel the
outcome of their duties and the
effectiveness of learning curves for new
officials additionally in a 2-year
terent these officials working full-time
year round unlike we
do start campaigning for reelection in
their second year while still managing
their full-time yearr round workload and
personnel
management why should these elected
officials working full-time yearround be
subject to the same terms as part-time
Commissioners who work excuse me
part-time Commissioners these County
officials support the change the New
Hampshire County uh Association of
counties support this change the RSA
chapters affected by this bill have a
plethora of carve outs for various
counties and in various subjects as each
county has different demographics
different populations different Wills of
their people and different Advocates I
urge you to support our large largest
county and press the green button to
move this bill along in what's left of
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report of ought to pass on
House Bill 1345 you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I all those oppos
adopted
the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 1460 FN an act
relative to the sale of County property
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative David priest for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with a following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
John McDonald for the minority of the
committee
representative John
McDonald's what reason does the member
rise for yet another motion Mr Speaker
make State your motion motion to
indefinitely postpone hb1
1460 representative Len turot moves that
house bill 1460 be indefinitely
postponed are you ready for the question
Division division this will be a
division vote members take your seats
let's see how many make it
in
Laur
e
house come to
order the question is whether to
indefinitely postpone House Bill
1460 this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
e
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 165 in the affirmative 160 and the
left
majority of the Comm the special
committee on child care to which was
referred House Bill 1584 an act relative
to home daycare licensing requirements
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative David pagee for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill a to pass
representative Ross Barry for the M
minority of the committee
representative Barry's recognized speak
against the committee
report uh thank you Mr Speaker uh it is
late and I appre I appreciate the time
of our colleagues I want to thank the uh
speaker for forming this special
committee I believe this is the only
Bill we had a divided vote on um so I
wanted to thank the ranking member uh
and everyone for working in good faith
for so many accomplishments that being
said let's get to the one we disagree on
um this bill what it does is it
increases the allowable number of
children for at home care So currently
that care is capped at three kids we're
moving we want to move it to four kids
when you're looking at this at home
centers at home care they should not be
called centers at home care is a vital
Child Care delivery system for
specifically rural communities that
cannot support larger centers so when
you're looking at the child care crisis
in the state of New Hampshire we have a
problem with access and affordability so
the only ways to address access and
affordability without running up a tax
bill into the hundreds of millions is to
increase the number of existing spots so
this would increase access and
affordability you must just just depose
that against safety and quality the
minority of the committee believed that
going from three kids to four kids was
worth the increase in Access and
affordability and did not significantly
diminish safety and quality so with that
I would ask the the body to oppose the
itl motion so that another motion can be
made does a member yield for a
question no member does not
yield representative David PES
report thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1584 aims to boost the
capacity of New Hampshire's Child Care
System it's a laudable goal which we all
share the majority of committee however
concluded that the life safety concerns
the particular Bill creates are serious
enough to reject it as a
solution the bill aims to increase Child
Care capacity by allowing unlicensed
providers to care for four children
instead of three in their homes these
four children would be in addition to
any of the providers own children who
they are caring
for while this change seems at first
like a modest tweak it could have
significant safety implications in
emergencies
the bill as written does not place any
restriction on the ages of the children
under care in other words a provider
could be responsible for four or more
infants during an emergency
evacuation I ask you to imagine this
situation during a fire in a second
floor walkup
apartment these safety concerns are
exactly why we have a licensing category
called family Child Care Homes
specifically for providers caring for
four to six children in their own
homes the majority and minority agree
that the child care shortage in New
Hampshire is an acute crisis
particularly when it comes to infant
care and particularly in rural
communities like
mine the minority also acknowledges in
the report that this bill will make
child care less
safe where we cannot reach agreement
with the minority is in their conclusion
that the compromises to Life Safety that
this bill requires are an acceptable
tradeoff for an only marginal increase
in available infant care
slots Additionally the bill will put
more children into care with providers
not subject to background check
requirements to put it plainly we agree
on the aim but not the
means rather than compromising safety
the majority believes our focus should
be making it easier for providers to
become licensed to care for four to six
children in their homes for this reason
the majority asks for your support on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
thank you Mr Speaker and I request a
division
vote the question is on the majority
committee report of in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 1584 and this is
seats
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legisl now Bill
1584 this is a division vote
representative Pell's recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this bill simply
increases the number of children who can
be cared for in a home daycare by one
child if I know that there is no impact
on zoning or fire codes if I know that
we need to increase access to child care
and this bill does that with minimal
government intervention and if I know
that we trust trust parents to choose
the best child care setting for their
children would I press the red button to
overturn the itl motion so a better
motion can be
made representative walner is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill would allow up to four very young
children to be cared for in an
unlicensed Child Care Facility
and that the four children could be in
addition to the child care provider's
own children and if I know that
unlicensed Child Care means there are no
safety checks on the facility by the
fire or health department and that the
provider does not have a criminal
background check or any training in
first aid or
CPR and if I know that expanding the
number of children in unlicensed care
will compromise the safety of our
youngest children would I now vote green
to support the inexpedient
motion the questions on the majority
committee report of in expedience to
legislate on House Bill 1584 this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
Maury
have all members presentence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 159 in affirmative 167 and the
negative the motion fails representative
Barry moves ought to pass are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I all those poos
[Applause]
speaker a division was called before the
down
the committee on Ways and Means s
referred House Bill
1470 an act relative
to okay establishing a study committee
on the fusibility and impact of
lowincome housing tax credit comes to us
representative leapley moves a to pass
and offers Amendment 071 H printed on
house record 11 on pages 60 to
61 questions on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay no the eyes have it the
Amendments
adopted for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker I move indefinite
postponement on House Bill
1470 representative Sweeney moves at
House Bill 1470 being indefinitely
postponed you ready for the
question thought so this will be a roll
call representa Sweeney requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
seats
need
the question is on the motion to
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1470
representative genian recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the special committee on
housing could address this issue and I
further believe that the special
committee on housing has a lat ude to
address the goals of this bill and that
there is no need to create yet another
study committee then would I now press
the green button to support the
indefinite
postponements representative Al's
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank
you uh Mr Speaker if I did not think
that we were going to be discussing the
uh subject of this and that and if I
know that we were going to spend spend
about 2 minutes on this and now we're
spending more on then on I would also
need to tell you Mr Speaker that I also
know that this bill is addressing a
subject which is not being addressed at
this point by the special committee on
housing or the governor's housing money
which is the difficulty for the lower
40% of our income Spectrum in getting
housing so and Mr Speaker I will on ask
this the questions on the motion to
indefinitely postpone House Bill
1470 if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are open for 30
seconds
e
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend to
the state of the
vote 164 in the affirmative 162 in the
postponed for what reason does a member
rise uh thank you Mr Speaker having
voting on the prevailing side of House
Bill 1584 I would move to
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote
no representative Barry moves at the
house reconsider House Bill 1584 and
vote
for
the question is whether to reconsider
House Bill 1584 and this is a division
vote if you're in favor of
reconsideration PR press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
seconds
represent
Corell all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the
vote 159 in the affirmative 167 and
fails the majority of the committee on
ways and means to which was referred
House Bill 1611 FN an act relative to
establishing a childcare Workforce fund
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate repres pres Walter spillsbury
for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Thomas
shamberg for the minority of the
committee representative Lee please
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the
itl this bill HB 1611 relative to
establishing a child care Workforce fund
in New Hampshire we have a consensus on
the two big issues constraining our
economy one is a lack of affordable
housing and the other is the lack of
affordable child care this bill aims to
help address both the lack of sufficient
child care options and its
affordability more than 40 Child Care
Centers have closed in New Hampshire in
the last few years eliminating 1500
spots for children forcing parents to
make ch to make hard choices some must
commute 30 minutes just to access Child
Care others have to work fewer hours or
leave their jobs alog together Child
Care is foundational to the economy
without it many parents cannot
work child care for one infant in New
Hampshire costs
$3,255 on average for a married couple
making the median state income that's
12% of their income
for a median single income earner that's
40% of their income both are well above
the US Department of Health and Human
Services suggested affordability
threshold of 7% of
income we have a responsibility as
representatives of the people of New
Hampshire to make a goodfaith effort to
ensure access to more affordable quality
child care in all parts of the
state
but the costs of fixing the child care
crisis are almost as vast as the costs
of writing the housing market this bill
focuses on a modest coste effective and
Innovative method working through the
child care
employers who know how best to deploy a
limited amount of cash to motivate the
workers they have to stay on the job and
to attract new workers to the
industry it is for that reason that the
range of incentives outlined in this
bill is flexible to allow for the
variety of New Hampshire employers to be
responsive to their employees diverse
needs this bill is a bipartisan bill it
passed unanimously out of the house
special committee on child care and then
passed on the house floor on a
bipartisan
basis this bill is a bill our
constituents want us to pass and they
have told us so 948 people logged in to
register their opinions
941 of those were in support seven were
needed in conclusion housing and child
care are regarded by Employers in our
state as the most urgent crisis they
face the child care crisis has kept
parents of young and school-aged
children out of the workforce reducing
the revenue potential
not just of those parents but of
employers and of the
state therefore this bill does not just
benefit child care providers who may be
the direct recipients of Recruitment and
Retention
grants it benefits all employers by
freeing up more workers to go to work or
to work more hours knowing that their
children are safe and cared for please
join me Mr Speaker in voting against the
itl motion on this
bill represent spillsbury is recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1611 would create a wholly
new subsidy program of potentially
breathtaking
scope this bill authorizes DHHS to
designate an entity to award so-called
flexible spending grants to eligible
private sector Child Care employers who
would then redistribute These funds
amongst their employees to pay for an
extensive array of employment
benefits and even wage
increases the bill includes no specific
allowances for any of the numerous
benefits no per employee caps and no
qualifying criteria other than one
simply must work in a Child Care Program
and submit
expenses though the bill makes no
Appropriations request it is plainly
intended as an empty vessel to be filled
as much as possible as soon as possible
with no clear
limits even though its fiscal impact is
therefore been deemed
indeterminable and even though the bill
offers virtually no guidance in its
open-ended Grant of rulle making
Authority proponents say the bill must
be passed now in order for DHHS DHHS to
begin fashioning rules so that the
program will be ready to go when a
future appropriation is made presumably
next
bium Mr Mr Speaker if you believe as I
do that taxpayers should not be asked to
fund a Cadillac benefits package or for
that matter any employment benefits to
private sector employees and that
Solutions addressing the systemic
challenges of running a child care
center must instead focus on root causes
then you will surely support the
committee's recommended motion of
itl the questions on the majority
committee report of House Bill 1611
representative Sweeny requests a roll
calls that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
vote
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 1611 representative shamberg
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill
1611 is a bipartisan bill that was
passed unanimously out of the house
special committee on child care and
passed on this house floor in a
bipartisan vote on February 22nd 2024
195 to
169 and Mr Speaker if I know that this
is an economic tool with a single intent
to establish the infrastructure of the
fund to be ready for any private
nonprofit federal or state Workforce
monies that come along would I now ask a
vote to expand the workforce for
employers by pushing the red button
against the itl so that another motion
can be made thank you Mr
Speaker representative Jian recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
while well-intentioned has no built-in
guard rails to ensure that funding does
not get out of control and if I know
that the cost to administer the program
is
indeterminable as specified in the
fiscal note and if I further know that
Ways and Means is responsible to make
sure that this is fiscally
responsible and this bill grants
unrestrained open-ended rulemaking
Authority in addition finally if I know
that the majority of the committee
recommended against passing this bill
would I now press the green button to
support the itl
motion the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient
legislator now Bill 1611 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of to the
vote 163 in the affirmative 162 in the
negative the motion passes and
representative Barry declared a conflict
and did not
vote for what reason does a member
right the committee on Judiciary which
was he as Bill 1640 FN an act qu
relative to qualified immunity standards
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is in expedient to
legislate representative Joe Alexander
for the
committee for what reason does a member
rise for a motion a motion please State
your motion I move to table House Bill
1640 representative Lynn moves that
house bill 1640 be laid on the table you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay
table
the chair Rec recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osborne for the
third reading motion is that the house
now adjourned from the early session
that the business of the late session be
in order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday March 28th
at 9:00
a.m.
questions on third read motion are you
ready for the question all those who
favor say I those oppose nay the eyes
adopted